[Laughter]
all day
[Music]
hello miley cyrus how are pleasure to
meet you
you also i'm happy to be here i'm happy
to have you here you have a fantastic
voice
not just a singing voice but you're
talking voice it's very unusual it's
like it makes you step back a little
like oh
i've actually uh recently i was walking
around in boston i went to a museum and
this like
older man walked up to me i had no idea
who i was he was just enjoying the art
also in the museum
and started talking me forever about my
voice and my
and then there was a college some sort
of
trip to the museum and then everybody
started freaking out
and it was so cool just to have someone
stop me about my speaking voice because
that had never happened to me before i
think as i was turned around and
i have the mullet so i could have been
you know anybody i could have been
anyone it's a heavy voice it's a heavy
voice
um you didn't always have a heavy voice
though like when my kids love hannah
montana by the way yeah
so when i i would watch your voice was
different
it's definitely changed i actually i
kind of learned a lot about
the voice and how our experiences
affect our voice i had a surgery in
november on my voice
i had something called reiki's edema
which when my doctor told me about it
he said no one shy ever has this this is
for abuse
of the voice this is for people that
talk way too [ __ ] much and usually
this happens when you're like in your
60s or 70s how do i not have that
i don't know i don't know mine i think
honestly
really i started touring you know at
probably 12 or 13 and not only was i the
adrenaline that you have after a show
it's not really the singing that affects
your voice as much it's afterwards
you're totally on and then it's really
hard to get that sleep you stay up
talking all night later the talking all
night
turned into smoking all night and now
this is kind of where we're at
we got some dirt on her you know she the
voice can be like like a face it
collects
wrinkles and and it tells a story if you
look at yourself and you go oh i didn't
have this until this
this trip you know i sat out in the sun
or i partied too much or whatever your
voice says the same thing it collects
dirt
it's very distinctive yeah yes it gives
me away
um i mean i'm pretty much one of the
only chicks in l.a with a mullet
so that gives me a way also well you're
not in the right neighborhood there's
plenty
i know i gotta drive out to the to the
desert i guess yeah that's right yeah
yeah go out to joshua tree yeah exactly
find the chicks that are tripping
exactly yeah with handmade tattoos i
have a couple of those too
but there's something very distinctive
about a voice you earned
you know it's true it's kind of like you
know when you see somebody and
and i think i think especially being
like a female in the industry i think
growing up and changing and like kind of
that
there is such a kind of stigma with
aging it's a very kind of scary thing as
a female in the industry
and um i thought about it a lot and
thought about my voice i actually had
someone when i was doing an interview
a couple months ago said you know she
sounds like she stayed up
all night smoking too many darts and i
said well i [ __ ] have
um and that's just the truth and if you
know that was anyone else you know it's
kind of like you're weathered or your
age or you've been through it and
you know we'll talk about it as we go
but they're they're
over the last year i noticed a really
big change in my voice kind of a
heaviness to it
and i experienced some heavy things and
so i feel like it
is a reflection it is kind of a scar in
a sense
um but also just by having the surgery
was kind of a gift also because
i was able to understand my instrument
no one ever explained that to me you
know i sat in a room with the piano and
did scales and [ __ ] but no one taught me
about
how do you have longevity you know you
are in here with athletes all the time
and and recovery days are the most
important days
um i didn't get recovery days there that
was not important for someone that was
making so much capital for such a big
corporation you know the off days are
days that that money's not coming in and
i i definitely
probably didn't get the training that i
needed to say hey you know what i don't
want to do this till i'm 15. i want to
do this till i'm 80
and that wasn't always considered
definitely not complaining it gave me an
amazing launch pad for everything i'm
doing now but
i hear it but it had to be really odd to
be working that much
and be a young girl the balance
it trained me to have is something that
i don't think you are gonna get taught
any other way besides jumping in the
deep end of the pool and hoping you know
how to swim that's the only way
i there was no way i could have prepared
for the amount of
balance i would have to learn to kind of
teeter because
you know at one point again it went from
it was school
then it went from you know how many how
much we can
actually smoke and still play a teenage
superstar on the disney channel
and then like and then like what's the
answer to that question
more than you would [ __ ] think um i
remember one time when
and i don't smoke anymore and i'm sober
how long have you been sober but i i've
been sober since the
pretty much the vocal surgery kind of
did it for me um
because i just learned so much about the
effects which again you're just not
taught
um it's not really the drinking it's
staying up all night you know once you
have your drink you end up smoking
and i kind of i i have um
i've become the face of a lot of things
kind of against my
will i guess from my opinions when
you're
someone in my position your opinion
becomes your identity and it also
becomes
kind of almost like um you kind of
become this like preacher you become
this
you know they don't really let you just
always have your own opinion so i've
decided to start telling people
i live my own lifestyle alcohol was
never my problem
there was other things that i end up you
know i like to go up
so i i now just avoid really drinking
because i i like to wake up at 110
um but it's never really been my problem
and i could see myself having a drink of
celebration in the future but
i get so [ __ ] hungover now that i'm
like why would i celebrate with like
just feeling like
a volcano's erupted in my brain you know
so so it's really just a personal
preference but it's definitely not
anything that i promote in i think it's
a lifestyle everyone should be
i think everyone should experiment it's
a good time and you learn a lot of
things about yourself and
the people around you but now i'm
watching i have younger siblings and
they're going through that and i don't
know how my mom did it with me because
it's scary
yeah i don't think i think if we're
going to acknowledge the fact that all
these things exist
cocaine exists pills exist marijuana
exists we should teach people how to do
it right
yeah really i mean you're leaving
children it's the same thing with sex
right
yeah we leave children to their there's
the information that they're going to
get is from other kids yeah and if
you're learning about sex from another
14 year old or you're learning about
coke from a 14 year old
that's not good yeah like someone we
we play this game with children where we
try to pretend
that you know they live in a movie all
right well listen to this it's actually
funny you bring this up because i had
the idea this week not that i really
have time to do this in the near future
but i would like to at some point in my
life
i want to do my own children's
book series of realistic children
stories
because i don't like the idea that we
teach them that this is sunshine world
and everyone walks on a rainbow and
everyone's equal and you need to say
like that's not what are you going to do
about it that's not true what are you
going to do about it
and i think there's a way to not terrify
children of life even though
i go in and out of periods where i think
life is really overwhelmingly terrifying
um and that's coming from my position
and my position
i tell myself all the time if you're not
enjoying this life honey you got it
coming in the next one because i better
[ __ ] love this life it's the best one
i i couldn't imagine being in a
different body and having a different
experience it's an awesome life if you
do it the right way
it's an awesome life and i also i didn't
hurt myself beyond
repair in my experiences i
survived and i don't even mean heart
still beating survival i mean
i have a lot of people that love me
around i didn't kick all the people that
had my best interest at heart out
that's the that's where you die if you
kick everyone that says hey
are you are you okay you know out no of
course i'm okay you don't trust get the
[ __ ] out
and so now that i have people that i've
had in my life i feel that i have people
in my life that i've known for
15 20 years and not many people in my
position get to say that
my parents are awesome my dad's loopy as
hell but i
love him so much um he he has no way
of ever hearing this because my dad
doesn't have wi-fi or uh
anything but a blackberry so i can tell
you what i got for his birthday my dad
has
two blackberries with eagle and a phone
which is not true but that's what he
says so for his birthday he said that he
wanted to see if
he could go 365 days without eating
pizza because he had never done it
before so my dad
has now gone a year without having pizza
and my dad loves bubble bath he's gonna
kill me for saying this but his country
ass loves bubble bath that's hilarious
and so he loves to smoke his joint eat
his pizza and get a bubble bath so he
said that's what i'm gonna do for my
birthday so
for his birthday i've organized a
five-foot pizza to be delivered to his
farm so he can have all he can eat
and i'm the pizza delivery person on the
box i had someone draw it where it's me
with my tongue out and a mullet
delivering the pizza
and i got a bathtub on craigslist and i
put it my dad has 500 acres so i put it
in the middle of the farm
filled with bubble gum just like my
music video and so my dad's going to
have a bubble gum bathtub and a
five-foot pizza for his birthday that's
a door that's next week
that i like the fact that he has no
wi-fi and no internet no wi-fi no
internet every now and then
he's good that way he'll drive to my
uncle's house to facetime us every now
and then oh wow
yeah wow he has to make a drive to
facebook it's not far all of us are just
like
my dad's kept us a a pebbles throw away
for sure
we all live on property we all live
really close to each other so if you did
this thing
like if you really decided to do uh
children's books like realistic
children's
books like how would you do that would
you get a ghost author and sort of come
up with the ideas of what you were
trying to
get across to kids well what do you wish
somebody told you
i like that you mentioned that no one
talks to us about drugs i know this is
going to be controversial to introduce
drugs to kids i think that there's a way
and i have to think about it um wayne
coyne is a good friend of mine and i did
the dead pets record with him flaming
lips have been my favorite band since i
was in fifth grade and he's obviously an
amazing
artist and he just had his first child
year and a half years old he's six he
just had a baby they're coming to visit
me right now
and um i would have him do all the
illustrations so it stays in that kind
of surrealist world because i think
i think that's what would get the kids
to want to read this book is that
that the illustrations are still surreal
um and i like that about children's
books but i do think that
we do need to talk about you know
equality and i do think there needs to
be diversity in children's books and i
think also we just need to talk about
the fact
i was actually happy to talk to you
today because i didn't get to do therapy
today because i would
be with you but it's kind of the same
thing and i was talking to him and i
said you know sometimes it scares me
that i'm too tough and
and i feel like i'm not jaded and i'm
not cold but i feel too tough and he
goes well i'm proud of that because life
is tough
and it's not to get hard what do you
mean by that what do you mean by you
feel like
i don't like that you're too tough i
feel that
i worry sometimes that
i can get over things easily i don't
fall to the floor and crawl up in a ball
the way that i used to and i think
that's a part of me growing up like when
you know i recently just went through
a very public divorce that [ __ ]
sucked what really sucked about it
wasn't the fact that me and someone that
i loved realized that we don't love each
other the way that we used to anymore
that's okay i can accept that i can't
accept
the villainizing and the um
just all those stories that like it's
just amazing to me that the public kind
of thinks that
there's no gap of time that they didn't
see that could possibly be what led to
this like it's not
one day you were happy on the carpet the
next day you were making out with your
friend in italy what the [ __ ]
well there was a lot of time in between
that that you didn't see it didn't go
i didn't like i didn't you know yeah but
you can't rely on someone else's
narrative right
especially someone who doesn't know you
you really shouldn't even read what
people write about
what's crazy is my dad again you know my
dad's been a real figure in my life and
um
my dad when he got his grammy nomination
he wore he went to the grammys in a john
3 16 shirt and he didn't get the grammy
and the next day the new york post if
someone put even god can't save billy
ray cyrus in his career
and he was sitting next to johnny cash
they were
going to something i have a johnny cash
tattoo that was handwritten
uh to my dad from around that time and
he said what the hell just like you say
to me right now
you're my johnny cash you know he said
what the hell are you doing reading that
yeah and my dad said i just never really
picked up the paper again but
again my dad didn't buy that paper it
was just kind of in your face
should have thought that was funny he he
does now now he just says well whatever
will get johnny cash to come and sit
next to me and talk to me now he now he
loves it
um and it's been really good to have him
go before me
you know it's it's kind of that buddy
system i think it'd be really scary if i
would have been able to see that but to
your point of
i don't click on this [ __ ] you know it
it comes into my life by
if i walk by a magazine stand which i
like to walk on the street and it says
like
miley's on drugs and pregnant and then i
think
one of those things are true but not the
other [ __ ] you for lying about me
yeah but that's all they have i mean
what when someone's in the public eye
and someone's as prominent as you are
you become a
way for them to access money right
that's all you are clickbait
advertisement and i totally get it it's
that unprogramming of
also i think what's interesting sitting
here
with you is that all of this is kind of
new um
i mean even just like the idea of
podcasts what i used to do when it was
like promo time for a record okay so
i'm 12 years old and i'm printing
physical copies of my
album so i have to write my [ __ ]
music
you know six months before you actually
so i just did dolly's new album for
christmas and i had to record a
christmas song in july it was the
weirdest thing i've ever done in my life
but when you make physical copies that's
what you do
and you're telling a story from always
being
behind especially when it comes to the
media so
now what i love about this what i love
doing you know a show like yours is like
we talk about it right now and people
hear right now so you're getting the
real information
you're not getting information from all
right you know i shot a magazine cover
i did an interview i was la la in love
with my boyfriend i mean that literally
happened when i did vanity fair
i flew there like a week after i got
married by the time the damn thing was
on the stands i was divorced it was old
news
it was like come on you know so you're
really not able to
tell your story in real time and that's
what i love about the new way that music
is happening and streaming and i love
the idea that like
i threw up that um flaming lips record i
did on soundcloud and it was like you
know no one had to buy it or
i sound 105 but it's very exciting
because i really hated always being
behind myself
and i think that's what now i can use my
art
as my kind of i guess the way that i can
talk
to the the press isn't what bothers me
it's kind of the public
you know and and i got in this habit
where when people would meet me and
because i didn't get to have it just
became
a thing that happened constantly was i
meet someone and they go
man you're not as crazy as i thought
you'd be and i'm like
thank you uh i don't know what you
thought i'd be doing right now if you
thought i'd be in like you know space
buns dropping acid or something but
people say that to me all the time that
i'm not as crazy as they thought i would
be and that's just a weird thing to say
to someone
yeah but the public image like what they
sold of you you know here you are
hannah montana and then all sudden
you're this very sexual singer
and you're doing all this crazy stuff
and you're on television shaking your
ass and everybody's seeing that and like
oh miley cyrus is out of control now
she's one
so then that becomes the narrative it's
funny when people make the narrative
when you become in control that now
you're out of it yeah that's
what's always really interesting well
it's also youth right like like think
about the marriage thing right you say
vanity fair they write the article
you're deeply in love by the time it
comes out you're already divorced
right that's so hollywood yeah i mean to
them that's like oh we've seen this
[ __ ] story before yeah we know where
this going uh also
you're a child star oh [ __ ] we've seen
this story before
and so you get stuck in that narrative
too right because absolutely
they want you to fall down the exact
same path they don't want you to
fail your past yes well then they'll
spell it out for you this is what she's
doing
she's on drugs and she's pregnant i've
had to con i've had to
now i don't read those types of things
but i've had to
unlearn that they're not true because
sometimes i write things i write things
down
when i want something to get put into my
head even if i'm gonna have a hard
conversation with somebody
usually i kind of write a little mini
script for myself so i kind of know
where i
i don't like going into something with
no direction where do i want this to go
what are my goals what do i want that's
what any of your athletes would do it's
like
i i know that i have that as an artist
i want to have a long career i have to
do the things to
be able to have that um longevity and so
i would write down
you know kind of a kind of an idea of
where i'd want conversations to go
even with the people in my life and what
do i want out of them and i had to stop
going hey just because they wrote that
down it's true because something about
writing it down gives a lot of power
i don't like to write down things that i
don't mean that's why i don't write
songs that i hate
because once you write it down they are
like alive
so what you're saying is that like
reading things that other people wrote
about you made you think that those
things were real so yeah
it [ __ ] with your own personal
narrative yes sometimes i'd be trying to
prove something that i didn't need to
prove
like all of a sudden i'd be trying to
prove that i'm not crazy when i knew i
wasn't crazy
um and yeah i just think also i mean
when we're talking about realistic
children's books i think the stigma that
kind of uh
surrounds you know youth growing up
rebelling and then craziness and then
what's the line between that and mental
illness and you know
i do have some kind of genetic family
history of
alcohol i mean that totally gets a race
when you're a celebrity it's like
hollywood did this to you it's like no
dude my great-grandma was an alcoholic
you know my granddad was an alcoholic
my grandma's an alcoholic you know so i
i obviously had it wasn't hollywood you
know it's
genetic i think for you i mean i don't
think there's anything wrong with
writing a book
and writing a realistic children's book
but i think you could do a lot of good
by just making little youtube videos
because you make little youtube videos
just talking
and explaining hey this is what i did
and this is where i [ __ ] up and this
is why you shouldn't do it this way
these are the drugs you got to be really
careful about these are drugs that are
really dangerous
and look if you want to have like one
drink you want to have
one drink like just have one [ __ ]
drink if you can if you can
yeah if you want to if you want to smoke
weed take a hit
yeah like don't get crazy yeah like
figure this out like you can
have a good experience on marijuana or
you could [ __ ] up your life and have a
schizophrenic breakdown that's one thing
that i feel like you know when i was
smoking weed
like my mom all the weed that i don't
smoke she
takes care of both my parents so i have
nothing against weed
my whole family is a bunch of stoners i
i just felt like when you're talking
about kind of some of the
the episodes that they can kind of bring
on you know i maybe have
a little some of those kind of
tendencies already
um and that's that's something that
people who love marijuana
don't like to talk about and i'm pretty
adamant about discussing that
yeah i i know people that have lost
their [ __ ] mind
particularly on edibles yeah i i know
some people that literally became
schizophrenic
and i really like looking at
i like looking at facts like that and i
don't know you know i do think that
there are
i like i like information i'm a real
i love to process new information um
i love to receive new information i love
to go
how do you get your information are you
a person who reads do you watch
documentaries
i read and i uh kind of
i was going on a i was going on a trip
when i was maybe 17 years old and i was
walking through the airport and i saw
a book that said change your brain
change your life by dr daniel amen who's
now
been my therapist for 10 years and i
couldn't get on this plane i was having
a full
anxiety attack with smoking a lot of
weeds i was taking a lot of shrimps i
was 17.
17 smoking a lot of weed and taking away
mushrooms and i started getting a little
yeah i started getting a little
cray-cray you know sometimes i recommend
that
doing some things with you know causing
some fights with my boyfriend that were
unnecessary
they got heightened um i remember one
time i wrecked my car into my gate and i
said this is all your fault i was the
one driving the damn car and how is this
your fault
i did not have a great idea of reality
at that time
so i was going to i was leaving the
country for the first time without my
family i was going to costa rica and i
was walking through the airport i saw
this book change your brain change your
life i'm like i
i want to change my life i don't like
where this is going and my brain is
actually i don't like who i'm living
with the person upstairs is like
annoying the hell out of me so i got
this book and it got me to get onto the
plane now i had a few
anxious breakdowns on that when you know
when you go to places like
going in the middle of jungle you take
all those little planes and all of a
sudden you're on a four-wheeler going
wherever you're going
every now and then i'd have to stop
because i would get so light-headed
stabbing chest pains and all this and he
said
drop weed first of all get rid of the
weed get rid of the psychedelics and i
also cut gluten from my diet from a
little bit of a time so i could get an
idea of like
what's my body on a natural level and i
started doing you know
kind of blood work and i i did some spec
scans which he specializes in so like
actually looking at my brain because
what i really like about the spec scan
is
you know you wouldn't tell me i have a
broken arm without freaking looking at
it i could tell you out it hurts blah
blah blah but like
what is the spec scan so a spec scan um
we might have to look up exactly what it
stands for
because i don't i don't remember this
but basically it's kind of like
an x-ray and it kind of shows you almost
like in those thermal type colors of the
activity of your brain
there we go single photon emission
computed
tomography yeah so i have one of these
nuclear medicine study that evaluates
blood flow and activity to
in the brain so that's my doctor aim in
clinics that's that's his uh website
right there
and so i have a couple of these um how's
your brain look
you know what so he says this isn't
right surprisingly good for the abuse
that it's had
because i started my throat but exactly
that's the amount of time
it's all okay so the amount of activity
if we're looking at like female and male
brains i mean they're totally lit up in
different spots
you know um actually i think he's even
worked with some some athletes of yours
he works a lot of like with football
players because he says you know like
you know i'm almost like a football
player for the life that i lead
i gotta do everything else right if
you're going to go and live under this
amount of stress which is pretty
abnormal
it's like you're getting hit in the head
an abnormal amount of times then i got
to do everything else right so i got to
be pretty diligent about my supplements
i got to really care about the food that
i my mom always says like you guys are
overthinking it i've eaten cheetos every
single day it's true
for the rest of my life and i'm like
yeah but you're not like a you know
you're not a superstar that has to go on
stage and do two hour shows you know my
heart really needs to be in good
condition i need to be in good condition
i can't by the way my mom has crazy
panic attacks so like
i can't have any of that my mom has had
me slam like had them slam the brakes on
an
airplane to take off and made me drive
home from canada to tennessee
i drove from tennessee to canada nine
times because of her anxiety i've driven
from nashville to california like four
times because of her anxiety so i don't
listen to him
off the cheetos exactly my grandma was
on a popcorn diet where she took a trash
bag to the movie theater
and filled it up with popcorn and she's
like don't i look good i'm like on the
outside
it's fine on the inside i'm worried
meanwhile she's going to outlive all of
us so sometimes i'll worry about that
but
i think i am kind of like an athlete in
the ways like if i'm going to be
doing this kind of absolutely type
lifestyle then
i have to do everything else right so my
spec scan looks pretty good but i like
looking at my brain and knowing
okay so this isn't looking at me and
going there's just something wrong with
me and i don't know why i had a head
injury when i was
you know two years old what happened
it's bad my dad had me this is really
bad but he can't go to jail i don't
think it's long enough
time away he had me in a baby backpack
and i was on a dirt bike with my dad
and he was riding and a tree had fallen
and he ducked and i didn't i hit my head
on the tree
oh jesus christ so that's what's wrong
everyone's asked me that phrase well
that you know that's a common theme with
wild people
do you know that yes sam kinnison got
hit by a car when he was like a little
kid and his brother bill said it
completely changed his life
we have just like a real cop same thing
with roseanne barr
she got hit by a car when she was 15.
before that she was like
mild-mannered really good at math after
she got hit by a car she had to spend
nine months at a mental institution
couldn't count anymore and she became
this wild lady
who who everybody knows as roseanne
right i mean maybe uh maybe i'm thankful
for it maybe it like i don't know
knocked me into this identity or
something i think there's something to
i'm not
sure he knows that there's something to
that dr eamon we've talked about this a
lot so when i get really overwhelmed
i also have a tendency that if i know
something stupid i just gotta try it
to know that it's stupid which is makes
it stupid because i already knew about
it sometimes i'm like is it better to
know it's dumb and do it or to not know
it's dumb and do it don't you think part
of that that's a head injury
well maybe but also it's the final
of your breaks but you know the way you
developed as a human being being that
famous at
you know 12 years old doing stadiums but
i do like i like looking at my brain and
going okay listen like someone cut my
breaks right
on my brain and i have to take all the
things omega i i've been
was vegan for a very long time and i've
had to introduce fish and omegas into my
life because
my brain wasn't functioning properly um
don't tell that to the vegans they'll
come for you that's they're gonna come
for me but that's okay
um i'm used to people coming for me and
it's gonna be that i call my salary
no i listen if i i
give home i have 22 animals on my farm
in nashville i've got 22
and my house in calabasas like i'm doing
what i need to do for the animals
okay okay but when it comes to my brain
you're not vegan
no you can't be vegan and living this
kind and not being this quick but
sure you can some people can i cannot
because it was really giving i was how
did it do for your brain
i feel that i'm slowed you down now i'm
so much sharper than i was and i think
that i was at one point pretty
malnutrition
like i remember going to um glastonbury
and that was a show that i
loved i loved my performance but i was
running on empty
like i was on i was on can i ask you
were you doing
a vegan diet like particularly yesterday
you're doing it but you're doing
intelligently like
myself the right way i do all my protein
drinks i've
watched every bodybuilder's youtube
about how they still
you can't pay attention to train that's
what i'm saying all of a sudden i'm like
those guys celery and like why are my
thighs like [ __ ] huge
like vegan bodybuilder guys they're
almost all on steroids
it's it's it's not on steroids well they
i mean
and they're you know they're different
bodies too some people i have good
friends that are vegan and they they're
fine on it my friend john joseph he's
been the vegan for like 30 years that's
why i think nate diaz i was stoked he
was a vegetarian
vegetarian no he's at one point or a
pescetarian yeah
that's where i'm at there's a lot of
people that function really well with
that but some people find it's
everybody's different you know we all
have different ancestors and our
ancestors come from different parts of
the world and you know i don't know if
the blood type thing is accurate but
some people really
believe that so this is another thing
that i like about seeing the brain is i
try to eat from my brain type and not my
blood type
necessarily my brain type so my brain
type
i really need breaks on my brain because
i did i did not have that where i
in my new song it says i can't bite the
devil on my tongue that was like a
really
hard thing for me to learn how to do but
instead of going i'm just totally
impulsive and the most reactive person
ever
i look and go well but my dad also
slammed my head into a tree when i was
two
so you know it's maybe as a dad that's
hard to hear that scares the [ __ ] out
i've given him a
award for worst dad ever every time i go
you know if we're on hollywood and
there's the best dad award i scratch out
best and put worse
um but he was also the best because he
would allow me to do a lot of other
crazy things that were awesome
well it you're fine yeah i'm fine my dad
let me steal
chickens from the malibu barn that
little red barn when you come down to
panga
my dad they were gonna feed these
chickens to the snakes and they let us
back there and my dad was like listen
i'm billy ray cyrus i'm gonna totally
distract him you shove as many chickens
in the back of the corvette as you can
while i'm signing autographs and we're
gonna get the hell out of here
so i did i went me and my brother got
all these damn chickens and we shoved
him in the back of his car
and he was gonna snakes went hungry he
was about to go work for david lynch
well he was gonna audition for him for
mulholland drive and my dad brought the
chickens in the corvette and he said if
you're gonna have chickens in the
corvette like you're playing the pool
guy you know that's a pool guy thing to
do
so my dad got the job so because he got
the job he had to stay in l.a and we had
to go back to tennessee so he told me
and my
mom to tell the people on the airplane
that they were
exotic himalayan cockatoos and we did
and they let them on the plane and we
had them in the purse and we
we they lived in a bathtub and like on
hollywood and highland in some hotel for
a long time
and then we got home and the night we
got there our dogs got in the chicken
coop made them all so they died anyway
but that's the kind of dad my dad is he
sets you up for failure and for
disappointment but i like that about him
because he made me tough
well i mean it's hard to keep dogs out
of chicken coops i had a dog got in the
chicken coop too
i had a lot of chickens at one point in
time and then after the last fire
out here yeah my chicken coop my house
stayed okay but my chicken coop burnt to
the ground
damn and then we had to put him in a
smaller chicken coop and the coyotes got
him that's the thing
that's the thing you can't blame dad for
nature that's the way that it is you
can't
dogs will eat chickens yeah they give
them a chance
several snakes apparently he is [ __ ]
yeah yeah
so you your brain like when they do this
scan
do they do they tell you what you should
do to make it better like what do they
do they look at and go oh you're [ __ ]
up
you know he works kind of with you know
i guess a lot of um
you know kind of mostly athletes people
that kind of live abnormal lifestyle and
and so
injuries yeah he just posted a cool
picture with tyson and he just works
with
all different i love seeing the other
brains that i'm allowed to see also
because it kind of is fun to
i would love like a match.com but like
where people just put their brain scans
and be like i like that one
that's lighting up the right where i
need it you know you got something i
don't have
that would be actually amazing that's
how it worked because
like personalities are weird like people
sometimes you go well
i don't they just work together exactly
and i mean it has to do with that you
know i'm not really looking now
i guess for as much as i'm looking for
the this i want the soul connection but
i'm more about the brain connection i'm
a very logical i like to have kind of
logic in my life because
i used to be kind of owned by emotion in
a way i was very emotional
and that's what i meant by i think we
spun off of what i meant by tough
so i used to be very emotional and um
i used to cry about things and now you
get over things and also more
like i would really kind of just like i
would just become such a recluse i have
that tendency my dad
my dad said he's everyone's just getting
on social distancing he's been doing it
since 1992.
like my dad's been on social i said as
soon as we walked in here you know i
it made me that was around achy breaky
heart time yes
right 92 is that was right when i was
born and that is when it was all
crazy so that also explains i mean i
think somewhat of my
uh just who i am my personality how i
how i did your dad talk to you about
what the anxiety was like for him when
he
became famous well my dad's your dad was
my deck for people don't know
in the nine early 90s your dad was a
[ __ ] superstar
but he had a very different lifestyle
than i did as my dad grew up
in a house that didn't even have an
indoor bathroom my dad hadn't gone to
the dentist until he was 30 years old my
dad had never gone to a dentist my dad
grew up poor
my his my uncle still lives in their
same house he's got an indoor bathroom
now because my dad's
a g and put that in but he still lives
in the same house
and um yeah so my dad grew up in like uh
you probably
have seen it it's one of the poorer
areas in the country my dad grew up in
appalachia and kentucky so it's my mom
so um i've been there
a bunch and i've been able to see where
my dad's from so he had a different
relationship to fame because he went
from nothing to everything
i went kind of from having you know
everything if we look at really the way
i grew up lived in a big house on a big
farm the only thing that was sad about
is we didn't have
kind of neighbors or normal kids around
because i lived on this big kind of
isolated farm but went to school had
this normal life but i mean if we really
look at it
i didn't know when i was a kid that i
had everything but i had everything so i
went from having it all
to having more and that i don't know
what's harder to kind of
uh to kind of humanize i guess about
yourself because
my life is is is very unique and so it's
very hard for me to
to sit with someone and relate to them
and i think that made me really scared
because um my mom doesn't like to be
alone so i have that fear
in my mind if i don't want to be alone
but i think what makes you lonely isn't
the amount of people are around but like
am i relating to people am i really
connecting
well you must have a hard time
connecting to people
because they don't have the same life
experience as you your reality
it's like you're in a you're in a fish
bowl you're in a different reality
and you're hanging out next to people
that aren't in the fishbowl here's the
difference of the fishbowl
so we usually put the fish in the fish
bowl and i
you know i reborn the fish right we do
it and i was born into it but then again
i put myself into it so if you get a
beta you're the one that does it you did
it when you were a little kid and you
didn't know what you were doing but my
parents didn't really want me to so my
parents my dad
wouldn't even really go with us to the
auditions he was actually kind of mad at
my mom about it
that was kind of a thing and then my
mom's like i'm gonna do this so you know
she stays in this small town she's gonna
be like everybody else that just ends up
on drugs
so she took me to l.a mom like hello
she didn't even smoke weed yet well this
is that's not the ab
that i've ever heard of like let's avoid
drugs in nashville so let's get more and
better a lot better drugs
in l.a but what what's we're going way
off track
what what bothers you about being more
resilient
because that's what it sounds like it
doesn't when you say more tough
you're talking about the difference
between someone who reacts
overly emotionally to something you
would follow the ground and curl up in a
ball and cry about things
and now you can get over them that to me
is a
sign of perspective okay so here's where
it is and i don't even want to have
a conversation about like really you
know sexism or men versus women because
like i love dudes you know and i i
actually relate to dudes a lot more
um but i think men in my life have told
me that i'm cold i'm a cold [ __ ]
[ __ ] because i leave when things are
done
i was actually gonna say well maybe
you've been dating [ __ ] i'm really
into a lot of freaky things but i don't
[ __ ] dead guys and when it's over it's
over and you're dead to me and we move
on
you know so that's how i feel about it
that's heavy and i'll do a lot of things
but i don't do that
and so i um think that that's where
i've gotten the idea which actually i'm
glad you just said that to me because i
i get this kind of
beating into the brain from all
different angles my mom's like you know
everyone else is proud of me for being
like you said resilient and i have a lot
of guilt i'm a very guilty person that
sounds like you're talking to guys who
want you to feel guilty
because you don't feel emotional about
it ending and this is the first time
you learn how to just let [ __ ] go if
they like you or if they love you they
love you
they have to well that's a hard thing
they should want you to be happy
just let it pass and then be friends
okay so
if they can't do that that's on them
that's not on you because you're very
older man because these like guys that
are you know i definitely should be with
someone i think that i got to find nick
nolte this is what i'm thinking
this is what i'm this is what i'm
thinking i don't need a man or
a woman that's gonna take care of me i
can take care of me because i've got
money i've got all the things that i
need to take care of myself i need them
to be able to take care of them
because somehow i keep getting into when
you need someone with autonomy
yes that's what you need you need
someone who they don't
need your constant approval and
affection and now that we're using this
word
need just for the record i guess i
really don't need to be in a
relationship at all so that's good we
got to this point see this is therapy
yeah you don't need it but it does sound
nice
people can poison you with their ideas
of what you should be
and if you don't meet up to their
expectations and oftentimes their
expectations of you are just to reaffirm
themselves
they want you to love them they want you
to tell them how awesome they are and if
you don't feel that way
you're cold yeah there's something wrong
with you because they don't have
autonomy they can't exist independently
right that's the problem right the
problem there's a lot of [ __ ] out
there
i like it you said it not me that's how
i feel and honestly
we're talking at a very uh this is a
super like
kind of pivotal moment for me right now
i haven't been single and like
i guess really from 2015 i mean there's
been little months so maybe about five
years like i've had you know a few
months here and there where i've been
single but not for a long period of time
and
you know something i'm really excited
about is uh this vma performance that's
coming up
and i love that it's the first time that
i'm gonna be on that stage as
a single badass grown evolved secure
um woman that's done a lot of work like
i've done i've done the work
and that's the thing is some people say
um you know
like how did you how did you get here
you know you turned out pretty good it's
like
dude i've i worked really hard at it but
just
seriously get it in your head any time
someone
gives you a hard time about being strong
you're not a bad person just because
you're strong
just because you don't cry as easy as
you used to that's ridiculous
yeah it's ridiculous it's perspective
that's all it is you're not a bad
all these [ __ ] animals you have yeah
how could you be a bad person if you
love animals dude i put this stuff
called monkey butt on my dogs what is
monkey
every day this baby powder for dog butts
because i
i got uh this guy one of my friends my
friend who said oh my god this is a
whole other story my friend who's
sitting out there right now tried to
immediately you know make me happy
because i just went through a breakup
and showed me a hot guy on instagram
and i started scrolling i see him
putting this powder on his dog's ass i'm
like i don't want him but i want that
stuff for the dog's ass that looks great
so i ordered it right away monkey butt
so i have a dog her
uh she can't see she can't hear she can
barely walk
she was dropped at a fire station she
was over bred she's a bulldog you know
and they
breed them crazy and she uh can barely
get off the floor
she's so overweight and her name is kate
moss and what i love about it
is i tell everybody when i'm coming to
set you know
i'm gonna bring kate moss make sure
she's good she's covered tested we're
all good
and then all the men on set's face are
the best because it's like i thought
miley cyrus is bringing kate moss is
gonna be the best day of my life
and then she comes in with her big ass
literally that i have
baby powder she has diapers because i i
put diapers on her for when she comes to
set because her butt is like atrocious
do you just need to get her on a diet
i have her on her diet honestly i'll
show you some pictures when we're done
with this because
she had this thing called a cherry eye
and everyone she didn't have both eyes
so they were trying to get me to like
either remove her eye or do all the
searching whatever i'm like let me do
this the old-fashioned way
so every day i get up i clean her eyes
see i'm not a bad person i
clean her eyes i put four drops in two
times a day give her three tablets
she's lost probably ten pounds already
and the cherries are completely out of
her eyes she is
healed and what i love about her and
i'll show you these videos
is uh she does she can sing that's what
really locked her in so
i've never known this to be a for a dog
to do this when i do scales
and i warm up from my shows she howls
and sings with me and she's got perfect
pitch that's cool so i haven't even
adopted her yet i was fostering her and
i was gonna take her to set hoping you
know
somebody's kids wanted a dog and they
would want her and the first thing that
someone said is a face only a mother can
love and i was like that's not true i
love her
um and so i love her because she started
singing to me and then i i adopted her
right then she's so
ugly that they waved the adoption fee
they said
that's not a lie they literally she was
free and i i now have to remind myself
they say the best things in life are
free and when i look at her and her big
ass
i know it's true so ugly she's free i
had a friend who had wolves he had wolf
dogs and you could you could
like sing in his house and the wolves
would start howling you go yes
see my my dogs do that with the
ambulance here oh yeah coyotes do that
yes
so they start going then my dogs start
going so all the dogs sing but they
none of them do it to scale like kate
moss
[Laughter]
that's adorable oh yeah she's good so
yeah don't let anybody tell you that
there's
something wrong with being resilient
yeah but people
will do that men will do that i see a
lot of men do that with women
they want women to feel bad they want
them to feel bad for for not being
emotional and i used to get small that's
what i'm telling you see that's what i
it used to be really easy to kind of put
me back in the you know kind of
jack-in-the-box
kind of thing you know you can get me to
come out and just for a little while but
it's it's it's become suspiciously
convenient timing it always seems that i
get told
that i'm a cold [ __ ] before right when
you're done right when i'm right when
i'm ready to put out [ __ ] music
it happens every day because you're
focused on other things
exactly and then it's like you know and
then i
it's just it's all it's a whole thing
you have so much energy like the way you
talk and all the sentences run on into
the next
do you exercise yes i exercise what do
you do i love pilates
and uh it's not super i guess cardio
i think you need to do something i need
to run a little bit more i need to do
something
i got a bag being put in my house right
now so i'm gonna next time i'm here i'll
show you i'll be here protect your hands
these nails come off i just have them
taped on this is dolly style
everything about me is taped on honey uh
it's an easy at night you just go watch
it
and i like uh yeah it's all just tape
people that have
played guitar and and musical
instruments and they hurt their hands
i actually had a uh i had a guy told me
that i had grubby little kid hands
and i liked that about it because i did
have dirt and that was because this was
at a time where i was doing drugs and i
wanted to know where the hell did
gophers go
so there was a gopher hole in my
backyard and i'm like where do they keep
going
i see them pop up and they go away and
i'm like so you're if you can dig to
china you can dig a [ __ ] find a
gopher so here i go
you can't really dig to china i know
that much and you can't find the gophers
either you can
yeah my gardener knows how to get them i
could not find the gophers and i
looked for a very long time i even tried
to get them out with pizza
i brought pizza down into the hole
hoping that you know everybody loves
pizza
apparently not gophers you rarely see
gophers but you see their holes
that's what i'm telling you that's where
i was trying to go
that's it you know when someone tells
you that they've been enlightened they
saw jesus and you know
whatever i wanted to see i don't even
want to see jesus i just want to see a
damn gopher
so i went into the hole and i never saw
gopher
i see a wolverine i'll die disappointed
if i was one animal i could see in
in the wild i'd like to see a wolverine
see you're like
that's that's next level i just wanted
freaking regular dagular gopher in the
backyard
you rarely see them but i've seen them
but i i think both rains are dope
well i just think seeing one of them
[ __ ] and that's rare it's rare to see
one of those things in the world
my dad uh my dad wanted to see a bear
for 30 years he had this dream this is
so i have some i don't know if he's
lying or if he's what the hell is going
on but we're on this plane and he's
so excited he's like i'm going to see he
my dad's a little kind of intuitive that
way and he's like i'm going to finally
do it i've been looking for 30 years
and when you look hard enough and and
you're diligent about what you want
you know i believe that you get it
through diligence and i've been looking
for bears for 30 years whatever
and so he brought catnip to he so he
could get the bear to come out i'm like
what the what's the deal so of course my
dad ends up going on some hike
and he sees a bear and he leaves the
catnip for as a tree he ends up leaving
and now i was so scared you know catnip
gets the cat's hype
right like it's like crack i'm like
please don't give crack to the bear
i don't think it works that way i was
just i hope to god that i don't know if
how would you know has anyone ever given
catnip to a bear i'm sure someone's
that's
very niche i'm pretty sure if one
person's done anything doesn't work
on dogs so why would it work on bears i
don't know dogs aren't bears i don't
know
they seem to be like more closer to dogs
like than cat like
well no bears ended up going ham and
doing anything
did your dad see a bear he was somewhere
on the east coast doing the show
there's plenty of places to see bears
you don't have to wait 30 years my dad
probably was lazy as hell and probably
said i looked everywhere probably opened
this front [ __ ] door a bear wasn't
standing there and went back inside well
that's what people think
don't worry there's no bears left go
outside look we'll just go to the right
place i've seen bears
i went plenty of i spent a little bit of
time in vancouver bc with my brother
this is actually one of the crazier
things i've ever done people think i'm
so crazy but this is the craziest thing
but it's not even that nuts
i uh i was following like nat geo on
instagram and i love the pictures of the
spirit bears i love those like beautiful
bears up in bc
and uh i kind of started reading about
the wolf coal up there and i got really
kind of invested in these animals and
i sent a dm and said is there any way
that some point i could go with maybe
some of your researchers and i could see
some of these bears or wolves for myself
because
i think i'd be even more inspired to
kind of like fight for them if i could
actually
see them and know that they're really
real because i've only ever seen them
from a picture
and they responded and said sure you can
come up and hang with the spirit
this is kind of like i don't know if
it's catfishing or i don't know what was
really going on but someone's telling me
sure so me and my brother load up we
i didn't really want to get my parents
involved so we got a coach flight
and had to go through san francisco then
we got this shitty little hotel room
because we were just trying to
how i didn't know how to do it
everyone's always done my travel for me
managers and all these things so i
was just booking it so we ended up
taking like two little planes
three boats and we ended up getting two
um with this dude ian who shoots
and uh for nat geo and shoots up in bc
and it was just amazing and when i got
to see all the spirit bears
um i got to go into like where they do
all their research on their boat so
they'll leave these like uh kind of like
trap combs where they it just brushes
the bear's hair
when it when it walks by so they can
understand kind of more about
it and dna yeah i started looking about
like all this information again this is
one of the
kind of weirder things that i've done
that i i didn't really know
who was going to be waiting on that boat
i mean i know we tell girls not to go
out into the middle of a boat
how old were you when you were doing
this this was uh two weeks after
the vmas in 2015. so you're already
super famous
and you're super famous going out there
to find bears with my brother
there i am yeah there i am yeah
and that do you find that if you're not
glammed up yeah
you can kind of sneak around well this
is kind of funny because they
i think it's happening in a second they
gave me a caterpillar that if you lick
its belly your tongue goes numb
oh great and i pretended that i was it
might happen somewhere here oh yeah save
the bc wolves
but if like you don't wear makeup and
[ __ ] can you sneak around
um yeah i sneak around pretty good it's
the voice it's
not the makeup i just have to shut up
yeah
can you [ __ ] with your voice and make it
high can you pretend
not really not really uh i have a phone
voice i think i i apparently you know i
directed this last video and apparently
when i read my presentations i have like
a different voice you know like when you
answer the phone
but i think it sounds the same my phone
voice i think is like
i think it just sounds the same mm-hmm
yeah so that's what gets you
that's what gets me yeah people know
yeah they're like wait what the listen
but the voice yeah exactly
that's the worst when you hear those
whispers yeah those are weird whispers
right yeah
yeah for sure your life of growing up
famous is that that doesn't end well
for most people you're remarkably
together
for someone who grew up famous you know
that's a
it's a weird way it's a weird alchemy to
put together a human being where
in your developmental stages pre-teen in
fact
you're hugely famous yeah what do what
do you think that did for you
what did it do do you think that's a
good thing or do you think it's
it's a manageable thing i would say it
isn't recommended
because like i kind of said in the
beginning of this it's it's like jumping
in the deep end of the pool and not
knowing if you can swim or not and it
can go one way or the other
luckily i swam but it almost always goes
the wrong way i know almost always
and that i don't think comes very
recommended and i i wouldn't recommend
it
um i don't know i don't know what it is
but i feel
uh i feel like
i've kind of been given this like
special i don't know
kind of special understanding of i don't
even know where it comes from because
i'm really not religious and and i
maybe it comes from like education of
getting a good understanding of
you know i've got kind of a good idea of
like what fame does on kind of like
if we're looking at it from a level of
were you thinking about this when you
were young
i wasn't thinking about this when i was
young but i started thinking about it uh
at the time where i think it kind of
mattered that i could go one way or the
other and that was probably when i was
17 and i bought dr amon's book
about understanding like kind of i i get
it why i can't get high enough
like on drugs and why i end up doing
more drugs than anybody else i wrote a
song where one of the lines says i'll go
toe-to-toe like i'm ali like i'll just
i'll do more they could be the biggest
guy in the room and i'll say i'll be
able to do more drugs than you
but it's because my level of what high
is
is i felt it from i mean when you're
having 15 000 people scream your name
and sing along to your songs it's like
you know how you're saying your float
tank is getting high without drugs it's
like that but times a billion
no i'm sure so it's really hard to to
come down off that
and uh i never luckily had a problem
with like taking downers to bring myself
down but there was a lot of people
around me that was like you know just
take half of these and you'll be fine
yeah you know so i'm lucky i didn't
start messing with downers i think it
also might have to do with your head
injury
yeah yeah i know that there's there's a
real big connection between people with
traumatic brain injury
and the the need for either alcohol or
cocaine
or absolutely something to perturb your
uh your natural state of consciousness
and a lot of my brain is really really
on
uh it's got like over activity but then
again if you kind of look at the part
that frontal lobe that kind of tells you
you know yes or no or stops you from
making a bad choice mine gets a little
sleepy sometimes when i'm not doing
especially when it comes to the diet
when my diet
isn't you know it's it's it's annoying
because
i do like to want them country so i like
to eat bad food i i had never
my mom used to get mad if i would tell
her i don't want butter like my mom is
like
great for you yeah now i'm fine and but
i just remember growing up by my mom
you know we ate frozen waffles and all
that we don't know anything about
nutrition i
i grew up on that country diet and so i
learned a lot i honestly i mark a lot of
um
my i guess kind of like my grounding in
the weight that i have to my diet to my
supplementing to
my my maintenance to the diligence to
the
sport that being an entertainer is it is
a sport yeah
yeah it is are you the boss yes i'm the
boss you're the boss i'm the boss
do you have a mentor do you have someone
that you can consult with when [ __ ] is
weird
i send faxes back and forth to dolly
parton because that's how she
oh [ __ ] that's how we listen that if you
need a mentor that's the mentor
there's a woman who's done it and i kind
of i i try to
kind of you know my life moves so fast
um i try to kind of send her a little
kind of rundown of what's going on every
other month do you guys facts
she faxes me then i send an email and
they fax to her
um they email the facts amazing about
that yeah it is
she uh yeah she she records everything
on the cassette and all that but
she records it on a cassette and so
she's she
i have actually um a recording of her
saying it it's somewhere it's on the
beginning of rainbow land or at the end
of it but she says oh i listen to that
she goes all right i'm gonna put this on
my cassette then i'm gonna run it down
onto a cd oh i'm so high tech
yeah yeah we played jolene your your
you're covered julian on this podcast
once
thank you very much yeah thank you no
when a lot of kids kind of think that's
my song now that's what i like doing
about covers i think you were talking
about
uh that cornell tribute at one point
also and yeah that's what i love my fans
you know they they wouldn't really know
unless i introduced it to them
and that's something that i really love
and that happened recently with midnight
sky and stevie nicks uh there's a sample
of edges 17 which i got
i got blessed by her to be able to allow
me to do it i had another melody
a b melody it's definitely below a b
because it's not edge of 17 which is my
top five favorite song ever
and she said you can borrow from me
anytime which like
that's awesome so cool yeah yeah that's
gotta be pretty badass
to be able to be in contact and and to
collaborate with all these
amazing artists and i went on the road
with joan jet for a little while too
when she was
on on tour with the who uh i went and
hung out with her for a little while
for a little while that's amazing you
know even if i'd show up there and i'd
maybe been partying too much and she
would yell
her manager kenny who's you know been
her manager and her band from the
beginning
kenny we gotta get her like some mexican
food or something look at her like she's
like
she's gonna break in half and you know
all of a sudden all this food starts
showing up my room and
you know i think she's probably seen you
know not just in her own band
but you know um i think she's seen
everything and i think she's seen it go
the wrong way you know how we're talking
about whether you swim or drown i think
she's seen a lot more people drown and
so she always tries to feed me
but that's where it's got to be really
hard if you're a woman like her who's
been there done that and then you see
some young girl coming up
and you're like damn this this lady
right now is in the waves
and you know and you've been in the
waves many times where
that ship is rocking back and forth and
you don't know which way it's going to
go yeah when you're a 17 year old kid
and you're doing a lot of mushrooms and
smoking a lot of pot
and and also you're super [ __ ] famous
and really people can't tell you [ __ ]
yeah which is part of the problem i know
that's why my mom's the best
i didn't understand she was the best at
the time she's still taking my cell
phone i'm like how can you take it i'm
paying for it and she's like i gave you
life shut up um you know and
yeah my mom still took my cell phone
until i was almost 20. you have like
an almost manic way of talking yeah your
way of talking is almost like a fountain
like a crazy fountain like words just
keep coming and ideas just keep coming i
know like how do you
how do you shut that off uh i am into
a lot of these i love the idea of these
hypnosis apps i have a lot of those
which ones are you use
i like uh i like amen clinics so i'm all
about my boy dr ehman
um i listen to headspace a lot
and i like calm i use that a lot also
sounds great yes i actually my favorite
thing about headspace is i love the
um the sleep skate and my favorite one
is the cat marina
because i do love boats and i do love
cats so that's a dream for me after a
long day
does that work on youtube when my house
burned down
i literally i'm not joking the cat
marina got me through i was standing in
south africa and every night it'd be
like
hello and good evening you're at the cat
marina
lucky for you you love cats what do you
love more
boats you know and it's like hell yeah
i'm at the cat marina
my house is on the ground in a million
pieces and i'll never see anything that
i loved inside of again but
i'm at the [ __ ] cat marina i'm not a
doctor but if i was i would tell i would
prescribe to you
some ridiculous rigorous exercise i
think you are
you're like a little ferrari and you
need to get out there on the [ __ ]
racetrack well let's go
i really think that like i see all this
[ __ ] energy you have i'm like that
like that lady's like an overflowing
battery this is why i like this is why i
like to work hard and maybe
that's i'm sure yeah i love to wear
you're a thoroughbred
i do and when i don't work that's when i
get in trouble but you also got to think
about there's
genetics involved you know your father
was a musician and you know just
and then all your life being in the
public eye like that and performing and
working and then
just the amount of effort that you put
in when you were a kid
touring all the time i mean you're
[ __ ]
geared for that [ __ ] you know and i just
feel like people like that
your body can betray you sometimes if
you don't i have a lot of physical pain
to be honest with you um and that's
something i'm working on and trying to
figure out too and that had a lot
you got physical pain physical pain my
hips like really really hurt me and
my hips drive me crazy like if i fly i
think i don't know maybe it's just
the do you stretch i do stretch i'm
actually overly flexible i'm like kind
of double jointed everywhere
um and so i have a lot of like shoulder
like my shoulder will just slip out
what all the time like it kind of just
does weird things and my arms twist in
weird directions
are you physically strong physically
strong i think i'm pretty strong i've
been stronger i've been stronger maybe
it's like a muscle thing maybe you need
to exercise
but i i really really loved
lifting and um doing all my weight
training my resistance and then the kind
of
the veganism i was kind of trying to i
think i'm really kind of building myself
back
up to realize what works on actually
right now in a very experimental period
it's actually fun to talk about with you
because i know that you kind of
have probably some good suggestions on
that but i'm
experimenting a lot with like my diet
and my body and my routine
and my exercise right now um because i
mean
kind of like you know leaving veganism
and is really terrifying like you said
the public kind of will destroy you for
that
how long were you vegan uh since i was
vegan from
2013 until 2019.
so in 2019 what was the first thing that
you ate
my my ex-husband cooked me cooked me
some fish on the grill
i cried like for a long time i cried for
the fish and i
was a little [ __ ] they didn't take care
of their kids listen i have some videos
on my phone of my fish at home i have a
blow fish that runs to the side of the
tank every time i come home so it really
hurts me to eat
because it thinks you're going to feed
it and i do every time yeah that's it
you know what i haven't really had you
get shot in the head that fish doesn't
give a [ __ ]
well that's what that's what my ex said
about the dogs and i'm like i can't do
this the dogs and he's like
watch this starts feeding them the fish
they're like they're happy you know
they'll eat it
but um so that's what i had and it was
because of a hip pain i had uh actually
going
to we were flying to i think poland or
something
on a tour that i was on and i started
sobbing crying on the plane because i
couldn't sit any longer because my hips
are hurting so bad
so this was pretty laying on the floor
pre-quitting gluten
now i'm back on gluten i did a trial
period of 18 of of like kind of removing
things because i think when you try all
these different diets like
okay now i'm gonna try keto now i'm
gonna try vegan now i'm gonna try this
you're doing it
at such a kind of it's really hard to
know what's affecting you
um so i tried to go slowly like okay it
takes a
freaking long time but going through and
going i'm gonna eliminate this now and
then i'm gonna put it back and see how i
feel
my body when i am supplementing
especially with the omegas like the
omegas have really changed my life for
me i think again you know you kind of
you kind of refer to me as something
like a car and i think that we are kind
of like a car and i was like
so dry from having none of these healthy
fats in my diet i did what i could with
like as many
freaking avocados a day as like things
but it's hard to get the fat
it's not as bio available and your brain
is you know your brain really needs
those fats and
you know it was really really hard for
me fish oil is the way to go
i know people don't like it and they
don't like the idea behind it if
but god damn it's so good for your brain
yeah i love uh
i do kind of like the fish egg vital
choice also because that sounds great i
love that fish eggs the way to go
that's what i do yeah i mean that's the
best way to get yourself so much
now that's an inflammation issue then
yes yeah yeah i think in general my
brain like you're saying it's kind of on
fire it is inflamed
i think in general i'm inflamed so i'm
looking for
in my life not just in kind of like
dating or relationships but in general
the people i like to have around
i like to have those kind of water signs
i like someone that can kind of or
earth science but i love water science
because i love being
and in general like i love people that
are kind of like fluid
and that can kind of put some of that on
my flame because
it's it gets overwhelming sometimes the
amount of heat and like energy that i
generate
i actually was reading something about
ducks that's interesting the way the
ducks handled their energy
ducks yes how do they handle the energy
so ducks you know
i guess their form of exercise so
apparently i was reading this in a book
last night i don't know if it's
i guess it goes with my real realistic
children's stories
but i was reading about ducks how they
like kind of ferociously uh flap their
wings
and then they kind of swim off in peace
and you'll kind of you'll
see these weird kind of uh patterns that
they do and especially if two ducks are
together so
you throw a piece of bread in the water
one of the ducks get it they get a
little
fight going on then they both separate
ways they go to their own spot and start
flapping their wings all crazy to get
out some of that energy
and then they just swim away in peace
and i'm like i guess that's kind of what
you're saying that i need i need to be
more duck like i need
to whether it's the beginning of the day
or the end of the day i need something
to go and like flap my wings and get out
that extra energy because i think that's
part of the physical pain
like when i when i went to go check in
on the pain before and i've been to a
lot of people
here and no one seemed to help me with
the physical
pain it actually gets really really bad
like especially if i fly i usually have
to lay on the ground
because my back hurts me so bad and my
hips hurt me so bad that's crazy i know
for you to be this young yeah that's
crazy and there's no real injuries you
could point to this that caused them
so i over did a stronger yoga for a
couple years because i am extremist
right and some there's a little
controversy between ashtanga yoga
and the kind of like hip injuries yeah
hip injuries
and everything looks good you know
everyone says we have no idea
you know kind of what's going on but
they're not really taking into
consideration my lifestyle
but that has to do something you know i
have to put it somewhere this amount of
energy
i don't always get it out you're right i
need to freaking run more you know what
the running helped me a lot when the
house burned down too in south africa i
was running every day
yeah i would think that someone like you
you need something rigorous
if i don't work out i'm not a great
person yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
i can guarantee you oh yeah i no one we
don't do
calls or work meetings before i work out
that's a we know this
okay we've learned from the past that
you have a trainer very important yeah i
do
is it a good trainer trainer but i need
to
i think in times where
my trainer is kind of like family like
for me now and maybe
getting a little too so too comfortable
a little too soft in the way that
when i'm going through like you know
this week i went through
like another public breakup i had the
vmas the song was coming out at the same
time and when i got into the gym like i
would sometimes just start crying
because i love them like families when
you walk in i would just start crying
because you
know that you could be comfortable right
it's comfortable and then i think that
it's hard to go okay now i'm gonna beat
your ass because i think he thinks life
is beating my ass but maybe i need just
maybe you separate those things exactly
yeah there's a job to be done yeah all
that emotion's great and it's wonderful
that he loves you and you guys are
friends
i think it's a little bit my my bad for
like wondering how hard i want to be
pushed
well it's also you're the boss that's
the problem when you're the boss
and you're miley cyrus you can't say
listen [ __ ] it's time to go to work
yeah you know
he'll do it to me sometimes which i like
yeah you can't do it too much because
then you're like no no i'm the [ __ ]
boss and then
you guys well then i think relationship
then i think i
i want to kind of i don't know what it
is not give up but then i think
sometimes
i wonder how much and i really don't
even like saying this because i kind of
have guilt for my life like i don't mean
it's too much like i can't take anything
else like i
know that i don't have the hardest life
i know how lucky i am
but i know that don't you don't need to
compare because just what
what you do is very difficult don't make
any
mistake about that i have a hard time
with that i feel very guilty
nonsense throw someone else into your
existence like first of all a
you didn't choose it okay you were a
little kid and he became famous
b being in the public eye and just
dealing with the things we're talking
about about
people writing stories that are fake
about you all that stuff comes at a
price
and if you read it it comes at a heavier
price but even just knowing it exists
get it gets in your head you have to be
very strong to be able to ward that off
and the idea that you don't and that
it's easy
and that a regular life is easier
horseshit regular life is just a regular
life
it's not easier or harder but what you
do is [ __ ] hard
it's very hard you're very famous being
very famous is weird
and being very famous your whole life is
even weirder
so a normal person develops right you go
through life and you meet friends and
you have to show that you're a good
person to get people to like you
you have to show you know some sort of
uh
some excellence it's something for
people to praise you
you're getting [ __ ] praise from the
time you're a baby basically
it's a weird way to develop yes and so
for you to reach adulthood and try to be
conscious
and try to be sentient and try to like
to just
stay balanced it's you're dealing with a
situation that
99.999 percent of the population has no
[ __ ] idea what you're handling yeah
the only people that are going to
understand it are people that also grew
up famous
yeah which i have a hard time with
because
i haven't made that exactly my peer
group and now i kind of
am like i think i've been really
searching for some sort of normalcy in
my life
and for sure and so i think i haven't
surrounded myself with the top
of of kind of people that are also at
this
at this level um because i feel i have a
lot of guilt like i feel like i would
be i feel like that would make me
shallow or something for only
surrounding myself for like rich and
famous people
right now but people do that because of
the only ones that can relate to you
and that's what i'm working on you feel
like people that are regular folks
they treat you weird or they they they
like you more than they should or that
they
you know they praise you more than they
should because you're an alien yeah
you're this we're like oh she's fair
she's working miley cyrus yeah you're
not like a regular person that walks
into a room and you'll never be a
regular person
and i think rather than trying to prove
like excellence in any way when i walk
in a room i try to prove really hard
that i'm
that you're normal yeah that's
exhausting yeah
but i don't want to be normal which is
funny so because it's kind of like
you make a goal you know i do this with
eamon about making a goal and then going
towards what i want it's like i don't
want to be normal
yeah but i i constantly struggle with am
i
a [ __ ] rich [ __ ] well this is the
beautiful thing the beautiful thing is
that you're thinking
you're thinking about all this you're
balancing it out but this is not a path
that very many people have gone through
successfully
yeah and so that's why you have to be
careful because you're here right now
you're okay
like right now mary's miley cyrus in
2020 you're great
you're good i mean you've gone through
divorce you've gone through this you've
gone through that
but you're right here right now you're
okay yeah the path forward
is treacherous it is going to be because
you didn't develop like a normal person
every [ __ ] child star i mean like
maybe like jodie foster like how many
how many of them made it through
and see and i don't know her maybe that
lady's crazy she's an amazing actress
right
there's a few that made it through
there's not many yeah and it's not a
good path
it's not a path that i would ever
recommend to somebody and once you've
gone through it
there's no way to go back and do it all
over again right but i say with
confidence that i feel like i could be
the one
because i i feel like
i don't expect it to be easy and i don't
even want it to be
actually i had a guy trying to be
[ __ ] me one time said you want a guy
that'll just do whatever you want i said
that's where you're wrong
i want like all the challenging things
if it's something that's easy i don't
[ __ ] want it i never have that's why
i didn't keep living my life in
nashville where we were the biggest fish
in the small
pond and all that kind of thing you know
i needed more
and the reason why i say that with
confidence is because i'm really willing
to do the work
and i'm also i'm willing to look at
myself from a human level
and also look at like what my body needs
to thrive
and i know that it can't be cocaine for
me and i know that it can't be alcohol
and i know that unfortunately i love
[ __ ] fish but at this point i gotta
eat it
to be able to have my brain to work as
quickly as you and i are going right now
or
what i have to do later today and going
to the studio tonight and
i i understand myself from a human
there's nothing about me that thinks i
am superhuman and i think that
i think i would i would take that as
something that
that makes me unique because i don't
think that i'm really i know that
there's something special about me in my
life
but i don't feel that on this level of
of being a human that i'm different and
so i know what it takes to keep
this motor going and and i also know
when to take time
well all those things you said are
perfect as long as you have doubt
as long as you want to do better as long
as you're recognizing
who you are is not exactly who you want
to be
yeah you want to be better you want to
figure it all out you want to work it
all through
and you have this weird guilt from
growing up in this weird way
it has to be you're a [ __ ] superstar
when you're a little kid the guilt's
crazy there's no way around it and if
you hang out with normal people they're
going to stick that in your face
a lot of people hold my guilt they know
it's a weakness so they use it with me a
lot you got to find people that don't do
that
yeah that's why my my crew is pretty
small beautiful well they're all nice
people they are all been my in my life
for over 10 years and that is possible
people ask people that are famous like
is it possible that you could find
people that
don't get weird around you yeah you
could find them but they have to be
strong people
exactly you have to have people that
have their own personal sovereignty they
have people that can
hold their own space they don't need you
they just love you
yeah and that is possible man you know i
had someone that
that tried to try to hurt me and say
that
i mean i i really have had i've i've had
really amazing people in my life but
i've had people that have tried to hurt
me too i even brought my little scarf
just in case i got
emotional because i really might i had
someone recently try to tell me that
everyone in my life is afraid of me
and that like that really makes me upset
just because well i bet a lot of people
in your life are afraid
i think everyone in my life that i have
in my close inner circle
really loves me and so to say that
everyone in my life
acts out of fear of me my mom i'm almost
[ __ ] 30. she will whip my ass
like my mom will actually hit me but i
don't mean it in a bad way
i don't mean that they're afraid of you
like like afraid you're going to do
something terrible and they're afraid
around you i mean
you're a powerful thing you're you mean
this there's no getting away from who
you are
you got to kind of accept that you're
miley cyrus that yeah that's a very
strange thing
there's no there's one miley cyrus on in
the universe that we know of it's you
and you're really [ __ ] famous and
you're really young that's weird
there's no getting around that yeah and
the fact that you feel guilt about all
this and the fact you want things to be
difficult
those are all the the best indicators
that you're trying to do better
yeah like you get it yes you do get it
and you know that you have a hard road
and the people that don't think you have
a hard road they're out of their [ __ ]
mind
like i didn't get famous until it was
much later in life and it was a slow
drip
into my 30s and into my 40s that seemed
to help cheer
it was way healthier that seems healthy
but i also during the whole time did
martial arts
yeah so i was always humbled i was
always getting my ass kicked yeah and i
feel like those two things are the only
things that save me from
my own brain yeah because you're you're
like people
are not designed to be famous yeah
that's why kings are all tyrants
yeah when you view the one person who
gets to make all the calls absolute
power can
it corrupts absolutely it's a common
expression right yes
that happens with famous i'm trying to
have a good relationship with the power
and feel feel a healthy dynamic the way
you're describing it is perfect
how many like look the ellen situation i
don't know ellen
she's probably a nice lady but she's in
control she's in control of all these
people they're all scared of her she's
like [ __ ] you where's my tea
you know that that kind of [ __ ] that's
not a good place for a person to be
yeah to have that control
that i don't live in that world and i
think i could probably also mark that up
to animals and how much i love them and
i think that's what led to my veganism
for a time was like
the fact that tonight i have to put
powder on my dog's ass
that makes me happy i don't get with the
power apparently
i think it kind of just hopefully
conceals
in some way how disgusting it's very
very
out there and in your face and i think
it's more of like a concealer
um but i'm really happy that kate moss
hey guys i gotta say kate moss makes me
put baby powder on her ass just use that
as the teaser
[Laughter]
one time kate moss made me put baby
powder on ass it's called monkey butt
so i um that that makes me happy and
like my
one of my dogs he's obsessed with
drinking out of the pool and so he like
throws up all the time and it's
disgusting and it all it seems always
makes me happy
and the one thing that i like about my
dogs that they don't know who i am
i mean they know that they got a good
living situation they're probably like i
wonder what she does for a living
but because their life is pretty good
and they get to go to other cool places
also
um but yeah my dogs don't know who i am
so i like that
and the cats scratch the [ __ ] out of me
all the time and the pigs are horrible
they bite my ankles i love it about them
yeah well i bet that's
one of the ways you achieve balance is
through animals that's probably why you
like them so much
because they don't treat you like you're
an alien they just treat you like your
mama
exactly and they yeah their their
appreciation and gratitude level is
something that i aspire
to uh kind of recreate in my own life i
love how gracious they are
i think i i really respect the way
you're looking at things
i like i like the fact that you know
that you're in this weird situation and
you actually feel guilty for it i don't
think it's necessarily good to feel
guilty but the fact that you do
yeah is strong because it shows that
you're conscious of how weird it is
yeah and you know we've been working on
my guilt a lot and what's funny is like
i always want to cancel therapy when
nothing's going on which i guess is when
we kind of need it but i always want to
cancel it
and then we start talking about guilt
and like we got it you know we got to
work on your guilt whatever but i'm like
i only call you out of guilt i don't
want to do therapy and i don't even want
to talk to you
about what's going on in my life so we
can't get rid of it too much because
guilt makes us do good things i feel the
same way about fear and anxiety
healthy to your healthy anxiety that's
one of the things i like about weed
that's the most
i like to get scared do you like to get
scared oh yeah i like to see the devil
that's my friend joey diaz says i don't
like that anymore i like to see the
devil i do not like i like to be
paranoid i like to freak out
i had i had a very great ayahuasca
experience that i saw some things i saw
like um
i guess people take ayahuasca a couple
of times end up seeing these snakes that
end up like
taking you underground and you kind of
meet mama ayahuasca and she walks you
through everything
so ayahuasca the woman that i was seeing
it was at the time where i just kind of
started to become uh like
really dedicated to the veganism and she
reached down my throat and pulled out
every dead animal i had ever eaten and
made me throw it up
but i didn't see the animal that it was
like i didn't see like a cow or pig or
chicken like i saw me puking up all the
animals i saw me picking up
seals puking up a seal not fun elephants
all these different animals and i would
see all the animals coming
out of my body and uh you're not
supposed to have like a companion
in your ayahuasca trip it's supposed to
be just about you but i uh
you know it like my life the good perks
i got special treatment i could have my
dog
so i had my dog and i held my dog the
entire time and i and i had a
really really intense trip but since
then i haven't really loved getting high
as much as i used to
it like unlocked something uh now i'm
like i just don't want to puke up seals
again
well that sounds like you were dealing
with some sort of personal
i was dealing with guilt yeah not just
guilt for being famous but also
guilt for killing other lives to feed
your own life that you already feel
guilty for
yes it's all psychologically connected
like what you
see through psychedelics is
in it's not just the psychedelic
it's what you bring to the psychedelic
that's why set and setting is so
important well you're supposed to be
sober
i think two weeks before you actually do
the ayahuasca which i was the only one
that didn't do that yeah i don't know if
that's necessary
i got a little crazy crazy tmt will take
you there no matter what i've done some
good dmt
so all my personalities greet me one
time on dmt
all my personalities i saw and then i
was like i saw me as like a really ugly
crier and then like he's screaming
yelling at people and i it was nice
as i was sitting on the couch as it
started to hit me they almost kind of
like accordioned back into my body
you know my personality the thing about
all this craziness and the
the manic behavior and all of your
guilt and all of your anxiety there's
something that comes out in your music
there's some there's some of that that
comes out in this energy
when you sing and i don't know if it
would be there without it i i think
all brilliant artists are crazy i mean
i've never met one that isn't there's
something that they have
when you know they're they're bottling
it all up inside
and whether it's they're playing the
guitar or what they're saying and when
they sing it comes out
yeah you know and when you sing it comes
out but it's kind of that tight it's
kind of new also like it's coming out in
a whole nother way
you know i i look at it you're different
i'm very different and i honestly feel
like
my voice changed a lot after the fire i
could sing better after the fire in some
way it's almost like it like unleashed
something yeah like it did and like
maybe that's what it is
maybe i earned it maybe that's what it
is because i noticed that
my voice got better as i
well it's also probably you're more
comfortable with who you are having gone
through that yeah
the thing about having like a really not
an easy life but a privileged life like
you've you know you've had
so many doors open to you and so much
wealth and so much success like
when you do something hard or something
hard happens to you
at least you go okay i got through that
that was real yeah like i earned that i
earned
my my point of view my place of peace
after a storm yeah and every storm that
you go through
like that's why when you listen to
johnny cash saying her
man i mean that is like how old was he
when he did that cover he was like
80. yeah i was that's awesome
yeah god damn you hear that voice and
it's like
there's something that gives me thinking
about it right
there's something that comes through in
the in the
muse in the voice there's something that
comes through in someone's art
when they've experienced things and this
is
this is what you're getting and this is
what your emotions and all that [ __ ]
that that bothers you and freaks you out
and all the chaos
when you get in front of that microphone
that comes out it's almost yeah i guess
your life
is almost like it's kind of art in the
way of kind
i feel like i'm always doing performance
art in some way even in my personal life
that's a problem right
that's good that's scary it's scary it's
hard to be in the moment and just be
you always feel like you're putting on a
show it is well it's because your whole
life you develop putting on a show you
know and we've talked you know obviously
i think a little bit about kind of in
the beginning of this talking about
technology
and how it's changed things for me and
streaming and all these things but it's
also given everyone a voice
yeah the people that don't need one
sometimes to say the things that they
they say it gives them a lot of power
and you've got to have a lot of
restraints like
listen you're sitting with someone that
loves to do drugs i can't take drugs
anymore i want to but because there's a
repercussion i won't
that's the same way i feel about looking
at [ __ ] and
looking at daily mail and looking at
these things i i won't do it not because
it's not tempting because in a way that
gives you a rush too right you look at
it you get those adrenalines and the
butterflies i'm
someone that likes to get high it gets
you high drama so i try not to watch any
dramatic tv
or things like that because i'm also
kind of a parrot
i'm a sponge i never grew out of that
you know kids they hear something they
can do it like i've always been like
that if you show me once i can do it
right now
but that's why i shouldn't watch
dramatic television right well that's
why i always feel weird when girls are
really into those true crime shows about
rape and murder
yeah no it's not jesus christ i don't
think it's really really that healthy
that's why i love rupaul's drag race
it's like nothing really harmful is
gonna come out of just slapping some
wigs on and calling it a day would they
do death drops when a whole other way
than what you guys do out there on the
mats this is like this is some intense
[ __ ] i have never watched
you've never seen a death drop what does
rupaul's drag race do what are they
doing oh my god what this is crazy it's
my favorite okay honestly
like rue paul rue paul
when i said earlier i'm not religious
that's a lie i am
rupaul's batarian like i i
[ __ ] with rupaul rupaul is god root paul
lives by if you can't love yourself how
in the hell are you going to love
anybody else can i get an
ranch in wyoming i love got it all
figured out
rupaul mamaroo she's my life and the
reason i love to watch her so much
is really there's this there's a thing
that they do on the show and it's called
the reading room it's called the library
what is the show because i know the name
of the show but i don't even know what
it is
you know uh so the drag queens from all
over the country and now they're going
all over the world they've got rupaul's
drag race everywhere oh [ __ ] oh yeah
it's all over the world i watch rupaul's
korea rupaul's canada we watch
everything
oh yeah oh this is one of my favorite
alyssa edwards
i think i might even be in the audience
you know who that is
that's what i'm telling you look at that
guy oh my god
you're the way they're clapping i was
here look at her look at her the way
they're clapping yeah
it's amazing oh my god whoa yes kick off
the trees
see i know who that is oh my god
that's a big person she's doing that
called uh
big big girl and she says wait come over
here and pull some more food up on this
plate i ain't going to the gym [ __ ] i
am
losing no weight look at me i'm
sickening yeah yeah i'm sickening ooh
i may be fat [ __ ] but you're ugly and i
can lose weight oh [ __ ]
i'm right there there i am oh my god i'm
in the audience so
are my two friends that are here with me
today oh my god [ __ ]
she's so sickening yes kennedy
you know kennedy is i know every single
one they all do the same move they drop
down and do the splits
that's what i think when i'm watching
your shows too you know all the same
stuff
but this this move of the splits they
all do this that's the move
it's the money move oh the money moves
look how she got money in her hand look
they're throwing it out
throwing money at her she's going to
split two she's an oh she call this
show i do the splits death drop yeah i
got a highlight video of all these
it's called best death drops oh i've
seen this one
so is that death drop when you do the
splits uh that one's a death drop and
split that's also a very uh
that's oh here she goes yeah ooh ooh
y'alls bam so is that a death trap
no that was a split okay what is the
difference death drop
you'll see it's when you go from
standing
let's see no that's a spoiler all splits
you gotta find death drops
that's not a death drop look up uh
it's season i believe maybe ten or no
season nine la ganja strangia
laganja strong oh there that's the
that's not that's hard look andreas
there you go what about jinx she just
does a bad split [ __ ]
that she needs a little bit that wasn't
great we love monet
she's miss congeniality monets needs a
little bit of flexibility
i don't love her so much
i'm okay that's funny like they have to
go all the way this is my favorite
oh so she's got her own show she she's
uh she actually did the vmas with me
now you have to she's a full split to be
taken seriously oh there that's a good
one
that's a good one that's a good one it's
a serious split i'm clapping
you can't have a bent knee is that no
disrespectful i mean you're not going to
get any cash on the stage
oh if your knee is bent it's not good no
that's laganja she's got the best one
boom that was her big split but she's
going to probably do another death drop
right here this is a real death drop
right here ready go y'all that's a death
drop that's a death drop
that looks like a good way to blow out
your acl look at that right knee that
doesn't look good
oh man if i was doing commentary on her
i'm going to go she's going to be hurt
that is terrible for your joints it's
it's got to be awful oh look at her knee
there she goes that's terrible cameron
okay here we go
michaels oh that's a full side split
look at that
my goodness that's a lot so when you ask
me why my hips hurt so bad at some point
it's practicing this no oh i don't stop
i do not death drop
that will [ __ ] you up i mean that's what
[ __ ] princess hip-hop no i don't do that
i tried it one time at g-a-y and it was
worth it what is g-a-y
uh my favorite gay club in london oh boy
they were just [ __ ]
nailed on the head call the club gay
it's so gay it's just called gay why not
that's iconic
what did you say what do you want what's
that what happened oh this one's really
crazy
oh no oh no oh my god that's the
craziest death drop ever
aces so that's wow that's a brain damage
death drop that's a death trap from five
feet up
honestly but like i feel like i've come
alive since watching this
what it does to me as like on like on a
level that i
just like it i love it so [ __ ] much
like why are they scoring them
uh well usually like usually in the ball
which is what you're doing you're
bringing it to the ball like you're
doing
a runway okay usually it's a one through
ten ten being the best and if you say
tens tens tens across the board
so this what's happening here oh this is
a really good performance that i love
um and these and this
these are the other pit crew pit crew
they're kind of like the
the [ __ ] that bring out the [ __ ] and
like they're kind of like
they kind of get um
that's what i like about the show too is
i think all the
the men kind of like having to be the
background dancers because
it's outrageous she's her name's alaska
thunder
alaska [ __ ] yeah she's one of my
favorites this might be my new favorite
show
i'm telling you a lot i have to start
watching alaska [ __ ] is
absolutely my favorite queen
jesus i love kitty girl i think you've
already had three or four favorite
queens just
well alaska is the one that i love her
personal music what about alyssa you
turning your back on
no alyssa's my favorite performer oh
alyssa is my favorite performer slash
dancer
oh i don't know and alaska alaska has
got amazing music
oh so alaska thunderfuck's musician
her big hit single is called your makeup
is terrible
[Laughter]
oh i might have to watch this [ __ ] it's
really good that's detox
detox that's hot she grew up uh hanging
out with her she worked at the beacher's
mad house which was like a freaky clown
yeah i met that stage before i met him
at the comedy store so she
i ended up i kind of that was like my
you know
studio 54 like that era that's what i
did so she was there she was one of the
performers so i know her
that is hilarious god damn it so is this
show like this every week
yes so every week it's rupaul and until
there's a new episode i watch the same
one every day
and who are the folks on the panel uh so
usually there's a guest judge and then
his best friend michelle visage and
that's todrick hall
who's like a big choreographer and
artist hilarious
i know a lot about this show you do
there they are how often do you want is
this like you're like
i'm so thirsty for new episodes i'm
watching rupaul canada right now
rupaul's not even on it it's just a
spin-off
what how about that canada if it's a
spin-off
she's a genius but she's the new
mcdonald's oh got it so she just said
listen i'm just gonna put my name on
this and just spread it out to thailand
and love it put it in iceland oh yeah
everywhere everywhere around the world
wow they're really fun to watch ones
around but without rue it's really not
the same because she drops knowledge
knowledge knowledge like what kind of
knowledge like when i do feel guilty
about like
all my you know kind of what we talked
about just like
when i start feeling that guilt and i
feel guilt that like when i tell someone
i can't do this because i need to focus
on me or i need to like take the time
that i'm cooking for you to be
using that time for my meditation and i
become that person like i just give so
much
and i just love that she says if you
can't love yourself how in the hell are
you gonna love anybody else i really
love that
um good point it's a really good point
i'm trying to dislike
that needs to be tattooed on my and my
brain well rupaul's also been around a
long time
also a really great thriller all the ups
and downs
and look what she created like from a
world that i mean still
even in 2020 that's just not acceptable
i live in nashville tennessee
it's none of my friends in nashville
they all don't know what i'm watching
and i can't believe that and it's just
like the way that she's won i think
she's up for like 14 emmys this year
what what was her what did she break out
with what was like the the first thing
that she got popular
a booty what sort of movie something
booty
um something you could look it up rupaul
booty
i'm going to be so annoying cause i have
the dvd yeah
was she famous for a song like yes
like you better work that's right
supermodel yeah
give it a twirl right right right what
year was that
when it like what is it 80s 90s that
might have been right around the time
your dad popped 93.
why he didn't collab that would have
been that would have pushed him over the
top
i really would have yeah yeah so rupaul
drag
that remarkable longevity for rupaul
right i'm telling you
paul ruth paul is the only one that in
my book compares the dolly that is crazy
if you really stop and think about that
that is
30 [ __ ] years that's that's her
oh wow
there you go look how beautiful
look at the exaggerated femininity that
drag queens
embrace i i love that aspect of it
that's called painting
that's called painting for the gods
painting for the gods painting for the
gods
show me painting for the gods i'm not
painted for the gods right now i mean
with the
makeup so when you're like you're
painted for the gods that means like
your makeup is like you have drawn on
that face
no is that that only is that a drag
queen expression
for the gods uh yeah
that one hung around we love drag queen
you know what i'm saying like there's
certain expressions from
there's even you can't say anything a
drag queen on the show
that is a straight mail that just does
drag wait what there's a straight man
i'm sure
yeah i bet you could talk him into some
gay stuff he's a straight man
gotta get him drunk sure he's struggling
all of us
he is oh yeah for sure i believe well
he's probably really good at it right
really good as a drag queen he knows
what's sexy he knows what he wants
um right i love that right yeah well
that was explained to me about
some men who like love women but like to
dress as women like there's a kink
yeah like they like to be i actually
dressed as a man
for rupaul's drag race my name was bj if
we can
show you that because i'm kind of like a
hot dude i look a lot like justin bieber
people tell me that all the time like
when i if i have a little scruff and
like a side swoop
i go bieber really quick really yeah but
my name was bj on the show and i dressed
as a guy and i i kind of thought it was
kinky
so yeah do you feel like a bad girl when
you dress like a boy like
is this no this is 20 20. like playing
with gender roles
is just so not there's no shock value to
it anymore no shock value
there's no shock value not in my
community
oh in your community of dragon in my
community
we're painting for the gods we're beat
the beach that's like you're beating
your mug
that means you've [ __ ] pounded that
[ __ ] into your face like
even if you took a wipe and went like
this you'd still look like a woman
like you have that's what it's called
yes beat your mug
yes you should see me if i had my brush
in here i'd show you how you do it
wow you just like pound it there it goes
oh yeah there i am there you are
oh yeah so they can't see me i'm in a
double-sided mirror so they just see
themselves but i see them that's you
yeah oh that's hilarious that is the
fakest looking beard i've ever seen in
my life
that's like team america world police
remember when the dude had to put out a
fake
remember the puppet put the fake wig on
the face yeah it didn't work very well
they recognized me right away but i
swear it's the voice but maybe it was
the beard
it's your neck it might have been the
beard my neck you've got a girl's neck
too femme yeah you have a girl's neck
there's no way you're a guy
it's not even physically possible are
you sure about that 100
yeah if i saw you if you were like with
the fake
beard on your face you would know and
then the neck i'd be like that's a chick
100 damn sorry it's okay
do some of those drag queens they could
pass as a large one so i brought a scarf
what if i wear this oh okay
i still cover your neck yeah you need a
hoodie or something like zip it up and
put it over the top i think you're a
young boy hoodies are fashion
hoodies are fashion i like wearing them
in my own time just don't want to be
wearing hoodies on your own time yeah
public oh why not because i'm dolly
parton's goddaughter she would actually
shame me to the end of the earth
so are there rules he's like i'm in here
telling you about my ayahuasca trips
this is all fine and dandy with dolly
let's not even start talking about
hoodies oh okay you know dolly won't let
you wear hoodies i mean dolly just
it's not dolly approved this earth needs
to be dolly approved
i'm telling you oh my god that's so
funny
dolly is everything somebody had a funny
tweet about dolly parton once
they said i just saw a picture of dolly
parton when she was young and she goes
in the the tweet said what the [ __ ] did
jolene look like i want to know who this
jolene chick is
right she must have been ridiculous she
must have been a [ __ ] 150 i mean
there was no one more beautiful than
dolly
she was about as hot as it was and i
love the way that she created like her
identity too you know she created her
identity from the town [ __ ]
yeah that everyone made fun of and she
was like i was looking at him like
uh this is an entire brand i loved it
and she goes i just tried to recreate
that
that's hilarious yeah and she also just
was so
nice oh my god it just came through in
everything she did it's like she was so
likable
man she brings merch everywhere and she
will get from the bottom to the top
whoever worked
on that set today getting a dolly hat
getting you know signed getting donuts
delivered
like she is just she's just as cool as
it gets i mean i do
think that that's a big reason too that
i've i've been able to not even because
she's gonna be mad but you just don't
want to disappoint dolly well it's just
you are very fortunate to be connected
to this like
this lineage you know the fact that you
know you're you're tight with dolly
[ __ ]
pardon like if you're a young country
singer a man
and you know willie nelson holy [ __ ]
yeah like you tight with willy like
you gotta you gotta cultivate that
relationship that was kind of my dad
with george jones that's who i grew up
around my whole life like
george was my dad's right hand it was
really painful for him when
he died because that was my dad's just
stake in the grass you know
yeah for sure yeah that's there's
something about that right like this
old guard that like nurtures the young
people coming up
yeah that really i really wanna i wanna
be that person if i if i make it through
the treacherous pathways
you're gonna make it you know i think i
think so if anybody's gonna make it
that's gone through what you've
you've gone through the way you're
looking at it is look it ain't easy kid
but you can do it you can do it well i
would want to be that way with the next
artist and i still
am like even from my position i never
like to see
say or seem like i think i know
something that a new artist doesn't but
i've been doing it now 15 years my show
came out when i was 12 i'm 27
gonna be 28 in a month it's not even
about whether or not you know something
that they don't
it's just what you know it's just it's
what it is
irrelevant it's what you know and i just
feel like
it's kind of you know i never knew
jealousy or competition
through dolly through joan through
stevie that's why when i reach out to
stevie she says like i know that this
corona thing's going on but can we sit
six feet apart in my backyard and talk i
just want to be there for you
that's what she wrote last time you know
and it's like going through what i'm
kind of been going through over the last
two years all these i think honestly
some of the physical pain is growing
pains
you know like i feel like some of the
growth that i've had stress
stress and sure and and quickly just
stretching like
beyond mm-hmm beyond you know and
i just but just a little lack of being
stable like in your mind and the tension
that stuff manifests itself in back
injuries all the time
people always have weird back pains that
are related to just
their life being all [ __ ] up yeah you
just you just you're
always tense yeah i i am i know like my
back cracks like crazy everything you
know down to
when i'm asked what hurts i literally
feel embarrassed to say from the
end of my toe to the top of my head
pretty much hurts a lot of the time
but i'm working on that pain management
and i do like cbd
cbd is awesome yeah i love cbd it's
gigantic i love it yeah but i freak
like for you i can't say this enough you
need rigorous exercise
you need something like really hard so
when it's done you're [ __ ] spent
yeah like yeah just laying on the ground
can't breathe puddle of sweat that type
of [ __ ] exercise the demons
i have a seven month uh german shepherd
at home so that seems like a good if
anyone's gonna run me partner that's
who's gonna put me through it so but you
need someone to go that's a good idea to
push you you need to
you need to purge the demons you got
demons yeah
yeah they're in there 100 but again
like you don't want to you kind of hold
on to them a little bit
because i like to use them to my
advantage sometimes music man there's
something about the demons that come out
in the music
there's i mean look that's always why
the the great artist like the thing
about robert johnson right they even
thought he sold his soul
to learn how to play blues the way he
did and it's
because it's because of this the [ __ ]
life experience
came out in his music yeah you need both
of the you can't be some person who just
lives in a [ __ ] monastery and
breathes in and breathes out all day and
then put out amazing art yeah
you have to have pain and light i know
that and i think that's you know i guess
one of our words we've used pretty
consistently today is balance
yeah i think that's pretty much got to
be my mantra yeah
well for you i mean you are
you're you are born into this
treacherous path you have this crazy
position
that you find yourself thrust into where
you're very famous at a very early age
and also there's also there's these
weird expectations because you're famous
for a disney show
right which is even crazier and then
post disney show
erased by craziness and wild and for you
know being a provocateur
and so now i feel like i'm breaking out
of like another role in a way
you know you're becoming just yourself
instead of a rebellious person who's
trying to escape the
the sort of the boundaries of your
persona
yeah well that's why i wanted you know i
haven't in my music video i have me with
the microphone with the microphone stand
and the reason why that was so important
was like i'm not just [ __ ]
getting naked anymore and swinging
around this it's about the music comes
first and i feel like
i think people are very visual and if
you can hold the [ __ ] microphone in
your hand and say this is who i am
this comes first by the way i don't come
without this
like at the vmas they try to get me to
get rid of my microphone
for something that i'm gonna be doing
and i said [ __ ] no
like what do you think i i i can't be
britney spears with the headset and the
snake what's important i don't want the
snake i
i don't want the gag um you know and
there was actually even some comments
that day about
um it was just an interesting
conversation in regards to lighting
because i've been kind of
learning a lot you know from directors i
didn't go to film school but i have been
put through that in that way so i
directed the last video and that's what
i look forward to doing in the next like
10 years i'd love to write and direct
and you know kind of work on film in
that way and
so now i have a better understanding of
cameras and lighting operation and so i
was just asking
some questions about not even on some
diva [ __ ] like i only want to get shot
from the side whatever i wanted the
lights to be turned off and that
uh the lighting of the of the room to be
just
lighting me so no key light no beauty
light and beauty light is
always used on women and i said turn the
[ __ ] lights off you would never tell
travis scott or adam levine that he
couldn't turn the beauty light off i
want this red lighting
they said okay okay we'll do it you know
what the same thing that we do with the
guys because
that's what i want and then something
that i was doing which i can't say but
something that i was doing for the vmas
my bracelets kept getting caught in all
the [ __ ] and they said you know you want
to be treated like a guy and lit like a
guy we wouldn't be dealing
with this if a guy was doing it and i
said well a guy wouldn't be doing this
because a guy doesn't sell your show
with sex the way that i'm going to
and i and i'm aware of that i know about
these conversations with him i had this
conversation with the directors talking
to me that's a
comment it's a ridiculous conversation
also embarrassing um
uh because this any the conversation
once you
see what happens on the show you'll
understand more um
if you see it but it might be hard not
to you know if you take walks like i do
you might see it whether you want to or
not
if you take walks if you walk down the
street and there's i don't know
maybe people sell magazines i don't know
about it you'll you'll see it at some
point you guys
he'll show me uh so yes and so so
they're
asking a lot of questions about that and
you know like
well how long is glam going to take and
all this stuff and i was like
i mean i can't really nail in enough too
it's like i did come from the world of
dolly parton and i love
pop culture for entertainment and
escapism and again you know we're joking
about the hoodie conversation but i mean
like you know for me i
i there's nights where i don't do that
you know at chris cornell i had on a
pair of black pants and a
[ __ ] chris cornell t-shirt that's
what it was right the vmas is a pop
culture show celebrating pop culture
and i wanted to bring especially in this
time of you know coveted 19 all these
at-home performances like
i want to give my fans escapism good old
pop culture
this is surrealism how hard is it to
deal with people that are directing you
like that
how hard is it to deal with like other
people and their vision and their
talking and their this and their that
when you are just trying to get out
what's in your head
and what your your vision is you're
getting it done you can
get it done but i the my two
the balance that i found is firm and
kind i don't lose my kindness
but i also don't become a mat but i am
firm about what i want
but in a way that you know you might
expect someone might say man she was a
diva she was a [ __ ] but it's again it's
like okay like have the weekend come in
here and say the same thing and you
would say
him you know or kanye is like a creative
god and it's like come on why am i not
getting
that i'm like you know a creative
mastermind but i'm becau
becoming a [ __ ] it's like no one would
ever say that about kanye west choosing
what lighting he wants on a performance
yeah it's such a delicate balance too
right because when someone's as popular
as you like you kind of you know what
the [ __ ] you want to do like
and if this person who you're using as a
director if you don't have a deep
relationship with them
that's why i started directing my own
[ __ ] yeah um and that's why i loved
making my last videos so much and
directing it was because
one i thought about my scenes almost
like a relationship you're having a
relationship with it when it's over it's
over
the what's painful isn't the
relationship it's that when it's done
you holding on for that extra however
long you
try to make it work something that's not
working that's what i did on the video
and that's what i hated when i was a kid
you know from directors not knowing what
they want and then getting frustrated
with the child for not performing
properly it's like but you're not
communicating and i'm a child
and you're an adult and you're not
communicating properly so you're working
me into the ground
to get something that you don't know
what you want um
and that was always really frustrating
to me and i think that's why now and
non-negotiable in my relationship or
dating life is you better know what you
want
um because i i'm just not interested in
taking you know another 10 years like i
did with my first love figuring that out
now when you were doing these like when
you're putting together music
do you have anybody that like if you're
doing an album or you have a song
do you do you collaborate with people
would you write the songs entirely on
your own
and bring them to other musicians like
how do you construct something it's been
different so on bangers
which i kind of think my career is like
a as a solo artist i guess kind of
started there i mean i mean not really
when i
when i started working you know on my
very first record um
and it was called breakout and it was
because i was kind of breaking out of
the
character how long ago was this like
2007
i guess maybe something like that crazy
2013 years ago holy [ __ ]
2007. i already had two records out
already but they were as hannah you are
14 i'm 27 yeah that's
bananas yeah okay so when you're you're
on hannah montana and i already had two
albums that were like number one and had
done all the things and so then i had
this like how much were you working
pressure
every single day every sunday too sunday
every
sunday because i want to jesus christ
sunday because i wanted to
all day i remember one time i came home
and my dad almost didn't let me go back
on the road because i was so thin
um and he was like what have you been
eating i'm like turkey cheese glasses
you know and he's like who's taking care
of you when you're on the road if it's
not your dad
my grandma my grandma my mom my mom uh
my mom has been my like my mom is the
reason i'm sitting here
so your mom and your grandma would come
with you on the road
and you would just go town to town arena
to arena
boom boom boom boom boom yeah sleep wake
up there you go here's the mic
you look beautiful go to school school i
did school the [ __ ]
kind of school are you doing i had my
teacher on the road with me who's like
jesus was
the best who i loved i loved it but no
kids
what do you mean no no no friends no
other kids just my little sister and my
little brother
how weird is that that was pretty weird
it made me it made
my sister's life a little difficult also
because her idea of like success is
completely blown out of proportion also
oh yeah
she fought and my brother too but my
brother is very simple and i love him so
much and he'll probably be listening to
this and my brother
just has his chickens and his ducks and
he's in nashville and he's in you know
small little place and and he's living
more
i i sometimes wonder if he's the
smartest of us all
i don't know maybe he has less stress he
has less stress yeah
um but he's also a [ __ ] badass talent
but he just saves it
he doesn't want to be on that level like
he wants to make music because he loves
it he wants the people that are
interested in him to hear it
he doesn't have the i gotta grind tell
him see how some [ __ ] that's online
right now he has some [ __ ] that's online
right now what's his name
brazen cyrus and how do you get does he
have an
instagram he has an instagram he'll kill
me
he doesn't want he has a spotify he has
a song uh yeah
um out and he did fallon and after he
did fallon he's like i don't think i
want to do that ever again i'm like what
the [ __ ]
he's like man i was that was too scary
no thank you and he didn't
i'm like oh good for him he had two
shows one at city walk universal down
the street and he said no
someone said i was fat and my hair was
ugly i'm like you know how many times my
i've been called found my hair is ugly
and he's like i'm not ready for that
he didn't perform again then he's like
i'm gonna try it again fallon i'm like
you're gonna go from universal city walk
to fallon whatever
so i go there and i try to change his
shirt and he's like no this is me i'm
wearing my flannel
you know the whole thing so he goes out
and kills it he goes uh-uh not for me
wow that's it well you know maybe
growing up and seeing all the crazy [ __ ]
that happened to you
it's almost like growing up around
alcoholic and never wanting to drink
exactly it can go one way or the other
right you either become my little sister
who kind of wants it
you know and she she's got a record out
that i love called the end of everything
what's her name noah cyrus and it's the
most depressing ep you'll ever listen to
she's 20 years old it's depressing
she's she's emo she's like an emo kid uh
she emailed me because she was on the
road she has a song
where she says um my sister's like
sunshine and it'll follow her wherever
she goes but i'm more like a rain cloud
you know it's like she's really got this
idea of me
um like she needs to go to the doctor
she is
we're all at the doctor a lot we we have
like a salary
doctor that's just oh boy we gotta deal
with that yeah she's she's dealing with
it she's dealing with it but she's only
20. so
i i worry about the hardest age for kids
today too
it's so hard dude if you don't look like
these girls on instagram right
they don't even look like these guys you
want to see something crazy yeah i do
my 10 ten-year-old did we were in uh a
restaurant she took a picture of me
my 10 year old thinks it's [ __ ]
hilarious when she does this
she um you know where it is jamie right
that
he'll put it up on the screen she took a
picture of me and she
she goes let me take a picture you make
a face i want like i meant like just
crazy kissy face and then she put it
through this filter that's me
no yes that's not real that's real
that's me
that's me through that's not real yeah
that's me that are you [ __ ]
that's how bad these goddamn filters are
what's wrong with your i don't know
what's happening with that okay so
that's the original picture
right that's me and her at a restaurant
and that's what it came what came out
and meanwhile if you know my 10 year old
she's [ __ ] hilarious she thinks it's
so funny she's like
that's that's not right that is how
[ __ ] up these goddamn filters are how
does she do that
it's just a filter and an app that's why
these girls are so insecure
because they think all these people that
they see online are perfect
but every one of those [ __ ] is using
filters all of them
all of them all of them and even people
that i'm friends with
that contacted me like this is crazy
like i use filters but that [ __ ] that's
[ __ ]
i don't have a filter on my phone and i
need to know though what your doctor's
using
like i don't even understand this
technology it's trick
it's witchcraft it's [ __ ] trickery
yeah i've never
i couldn't believe that was really the
only thing i have on my phone is where i
can swipe
on uh the instagram story thingy and
turn paris
you know where it kind of blurs out your
pores or something that's all i got
don't even use that it's ridiculous it
looks pretty good no you look great you
don't need that [ __ ]
no it makes you look like a cartoon he
doesn't make it i don't do any of this
[ __ ] with like girls want that
they want like no flaws they want
everything to be like cloudy
yeah i don't know that's basically what
it does it makes you look like but
that's
not good i know i know there's so much
unprogramming to do on me
so much on everybody there's so much
time programming it's all these women
out there that are
they're these unrealistic expectations
like i'm sure you saw that khloe
kardashian picture that looks nothing
like her
where it like goes from like the
hairlines like
yeah nonsense they did they used they
used photoshop on her i mean it's like
cgi
you might as well be looking at a
monster movie like when she turns into a
werewolf it's not what that's not who
she is
no it's crazy i mean and even like for
me i think
you know in my real life i don't wear
any makeup i don't even like today
someone asked me like what do you use on
your hair and i'm like shampoo and
conditioner like i don't do anything to
my hair i don't really do anything
and that's been really [ __ ] tough for
me over the last few months too because
i don't know why i guess i i
i think as that keeps happening like as
these technology things keep happening
on instagram these filters keep getting
better and better
i'm compared to the people altering
you know themselves either physically
like with all these
things you can do and lasers and all the
[ __ ] or to the filters and i've had a
really hard time with that you know and
i think
um it's hard for me the other day you
know i get packed walking around my
neighborhood in like a really shitty
dirty
fleetwood mac t-shirt that i've been in
for five days
and it hurts just don't go online
just just detox from all that [ __ ] no
why don't i
be ray just don't pay attention to all
these other women that are doing these
[ __ ] wacky filters because that's
where everybody gets [ __ ] up it's the
comparison thing
there's a book called the coddling of
the american mind
by jonathan height and he talks about
young girls and depression
yes gigantic uptick in depression that
directly coincides with the invention of
the iphone
and that as the iphone came up and then
pictures and then
social media apps so at first it was a
lot of it was social media
and people being mean to each other on
twitter and all those things because
you're not seeing each other
there's not a lot about this about the
iphone kind of i guess
mimicking right vegas uh slot machines
and things oh yeah
like there's it's actually isn't it i
think it was called what i listen to is
the slot machine in your pocket
yeah well it is a lot like that but the
thing about it with women in particular
with young girls
is that they're comparing themselves to
these cartoons
these people that aren't even like that
picture of me you know when i got sober
i had to delete all the apps
on my phone where i could purchase
things like i had to take off amazon and
all the things on my phone because
walking around with that slot machine in
my pocket all of a sudden i'm getting
these bills and things and
and yes i care about that and i want to
live financially
responsibly and all the things and i'm
looking at this i'm like i don't even
remember doing this like it's totally
like being high on drugs
it is and things started showing up and
you're like what the hell it's too easy
i'm in the middle of a book now about
that it's called irresistible
you find that it's on my instagram too
jamie
um irresistible is this book that is
about how people are addicted
it's by uh adam alter and uh it's about
how people are addicted
to your phones and applications but it
also goes into
just the actual physical aspect of
addiction and how it works on the brain
and how we always like to think of
addiction as like it's something that
you get hooked physically and you can't
live without it
no it's something that you have a
compulsion to to use
and you can't avoid that compulsion for
some reason and it doesn't even
necessarily have to be good
no and it can happen it can happen with
things like love
and i mean i've even felt that too when
it's like
in the most stressful times of my life
it's like okay i can't reach for drugs
anymore okay i don't want to reach for
bad food all right i'm going to reach
for someone to love me and it's like you
know coming down from something all the
time
part of love is the most powerful drug
you're ever going to take it's like
cocaine when you yeah it's dopamine
straight dopamine right to the [ __ ] v
dr amon has a book brain in love and
i've
read it a lot because i had a tendency
to to need someone in my life at all
times and i
actually now i i really love just
factual information so you can go i'm
not a total
freak that's got this a d i'm not a love
addict this is actually
what is happening to me on a level of
this is uncontrollable
of you can control how it affects you
and what you're
i guess you kind of learn to control
your reaction exactly you can control
your reaction
but when you love someone the first
couple of months
you know you do feel like you're high on
drugs it is it is it's the same
it's the same drip it really is it's
dopamine
he writes how it kind of goes from like
more like cocaine which is kind of a
quick hit and
wears off really quickly so you need a
lot of it and then it becomes more like
you know kind of like heroin where it's
something that almost sues you actually
i i i
called the the love of mine who i was
with and we got divorced it was almost
like a pacifier
like it was that thing that i just
needed not because we were in love
anymore
but because of the comfort and cause my
brain said oh this feels better this is
comforting
but actually knowing that i was giving
in to an addiction made me feel
way worse i had the hangover next day
okay we sleep together next day we wake
up
i'm totally hungover yeah you know it
felt like a relapse every time i go back
well people do it to each other you know
it's not even anybody's fault it's like
you you don't even realize that you're a
part of this drug cycle
yeah and then you get involved in that
and then you find some new person and
you get lit up
yeah maybe some new person you see at
the gym or at the office or wherever you
meet people and you're like
well what's funny what's funny about
this is like you know i guess i just
realized something about myself is
all of a sudden it's like unavoidable
you know i'm telling you this is not
true so this is where i now retract what
i've said because i
i need to i need to work on this a
little bit so it's like okay it's so
untrue for me to see all these bad
things they're in my face no matter what
no matter what i want to look at or not
i have a really hard time looking at the
good things like when people send me the
stats of my song i don't open it
when people send me the charts or the
views i don't open it because i don't
want to get attached to success or
numbers or
mean that my art everyone said literally
i'll show you the text manager he said
unless it's a drag queen death dropping
to her new single don't even bother
sending it to her because she's not
going to open it
and i think that's good that's a sign of
you avoiding narcissism but i wonder why
i feel like
i can avoid i can't avoid the bad things
and looking at them like i'm
maybe a little addiction of that of
looking at that but then
why don't i want the hit of the
positivity of like seeing the numbers
because you want to work hard because
you want things to be difficult when you
see too much success you don't want to
slack off i have no idea how many people
listen to my song i have the same thing
yeah i can't have the same thing i have
the same thing with podcasts or the same
thing with comedy specials i don't
read any of their reviews i just keep
moving that's what i don't always do
that
and everyone's like you want to hear
some stats i'm like i literally you can
ask them i say i won't even know what it
means jamie will tell me some stats
every now and then
and i'll just go what the [ __ ] means
yeah
it's well it gets nuts yeah i don't know
what it means yeah what does it mean and
a lot of the three million streams
what does that mean in the world of like
how many seven billion
it's never good enough for me it doesn't
mean like three million seven billion
i could do better right exactly yeah
three million is not enough
well that's i think that's a sign that
you're looking at things the right way i
really do because i think that's a sign
of you
you know what you were talking about
earlier you want to struggle you want to
you want to earn it you know because you
think that you kind of got
these crazy gifts being famous at a
young age and all this wealth and
success at a young age you want to earn
it so when you see success and the
trappings of success or
wallowing around in all of your fortune
you don't want to do that
you want to hustle you want to keep
going i think that's a good sign yeah
i really do yeah yeah that's why yeah at
some point
you know you can bring your kids maybe
she can do that weird [ __ ] up thing to
my face whatever you should come and see
some of the animals especially
in your nashville i think you'll totally
get it i think you'll totally get if
you're ever in tennessee and you come
out to the farm and you see the horses
and you see the pigs bite my ankles and
all these things i'm sure
i think i think you'll you'll get a
really good balance good understanding
of my life and who i am
my last comedy special that i filmed uh
was strange times for netflix
and when i was when i warm up for shows
i've done all the work
i like to just put my brain in another
place and i was listening to malibu
and that's that's what i thought you're
going to say all the people
on the set were making fun of me so my
friend anthony giordano who also directs
the ufc by the way yeah because he's
imagining a good friend of mine
he's like what are you listening to i go
miley cyrus and like he's like shut the
[ __ ] up i go look i go listen to it i
put the headsets on him and i had him
listen to it but that song is so
removed from anything in me or or my
life and i love your voice
thank you so it's it's a little escape
for me that's cool so i'd be like
dancing backstage
high as [ __ ] getting ready to go on
stage listening to your song yeah
that was the first song well no because
i had done dead pets
uh dead pets was where i started writing
like my
music where if you know you look at the
list it says cause
what's funny okay so if you look at
stevie nick songs things have changed a
lot in
in credits a lot of it says written by
stevie nicks and it doesn't says any
other writers but there are other
writers because there's music that was
written she didn't play every guitar
part and every piano part etc
now it's changed in our credits and the
way we do things so actually you have to
put
written by for anyone that wrote
anything musical on the song so any
guitar parts all that [ __ ]
so if you start looking at some of the
dead pet stuff it'll say written by and
they'll say a group of people but all
the lyrics were written by me it's just
any of the
melodic stuff in the track is that all
stuff that's new for
for money purposes yeah and i think the
way that now streaming is kind of making
things a little bit more difficult
because you don't pay someone the way
that you would record when record sales
they get their money whatever so that
it's something to do with that it's very
complex
and they say that some of the best
lawyers don't even understand quite
what's going on in the music industry
right now because we're having such uh
change such a shift in the way that
everything's happening
from sec sales of records of records to
streaming to videos to tick tocks tick
tock is like a freaking label now
so they pay tick-tockers to tick-tock to
your music because it counts as streams
i don't even understand it
i don't even understand it but this is a
thing tick-tock is weird
do you pay attention all that [ __ ] with
it's like the chinese government owns it
no it's very i mean i know that that's a
thing i also know that
it was like you know this is the new way
of the new label
basically labels pay tick-tock to be
able to have these kids doing i don't
know if i'm supposed to say it but they
[ __ ] do so then i said it please say
it
that's all i know is like it's true so
say it so they pay
kids to tick-tock to certain so say if
you're a tick-tocker you're like a
big-time teacher there's like rich
tick-tockers that are like
that from like millions i don't know
about millions we have maybe a different
idea of like richie rich but for kids
living in a house here that there's tick
tock agencies yes tick tock
agencies so they like uh marcia i see a
tick tock and
it's like a big big mirror i'm telling
you it's like some [ __ ] up black
mirror [ __ ] wow
interesting i didn't but the one thing
that i told the kids that you know
these kind of influencers i've spoken to
some of them before by doing some of
this press you know they
want me to play the song for them
whatever and the one thing that i said
that i like is like at least it's kids
creating content for themselves
because i used that to go through all
the middle men before before i could put
out a [ __ ] video i had to ask
hey gary marsh at disney is this okay
hey this person can i do this
but now it's like [ __ ] grab your phone
put it up you're in control of your own
destiny
right you could i mean if you wanted to
you could set your phone up and just go
live on youtube and play an acoustic set
and do whatever the [ __ ] i love that
about that so i love that about today
yeah me too
i love that amazing um and yeah so so
kind of to that point was
when i was working on younger now that
was the first record i was going to put
out that was
for sale because i did soundcloud with
my flaming lips record so because i said
people don't want to hear me singing a
song called bang my box about me
like having sex at a lesbian strip club
well then i'm not going to ask them to
buy it i'm just gonna give it to him as
a gift and you're really the worst thing
they can do with a gift is throw it away
or not open it like
well that's mine good thing of being in
the position where you're in that you
could call the shop
exactly and it's like listen okay you're
not gonna make money off of it's like
hey that's fine
i'm sure they're still selling a
toothbrush somewhere that plays my
[ __ ] song and i'll get a dollar from
that are there any tick tockers out
there to bang my box
i don't think anyone's tick talking to
bang my box jamie can you uh
research that please i do i honestly i
think everything
on the internet's been done but i don't
think people tic-tac-toe
love to see a bunch of rupaul's drag
queens tick-tocking to bang my box
i don't think it's happening my box is
very very niche
we can make that happen i feel like we
could put that out there into the
internet
now i'm trying to find a good version to
show i'm trying to be quick about it
i'm scared well listen jamie can find it
if it's out there
he has connections to the dark
he's the best googler on the planet
there's no one even close
yes he's a one-handed best googler too i
know look at this
he googles with one hand while he's
working the camera together oh my god
let me give you some volume uh let me
hear a little bit look at this guy
so we got um a dude
oh okay there you go look this is how
[ __ ] it is it's got two [ __ ] likes
listen for now it has two likes now
people know about it
and now it'll have more influence i'll
retweet that [ __ ] later
send that to me and i'll retweet it i
want you to bang my box
the point being is that that was free
and then getting to write younger now
and writing malibu i wrote that in the
back of the car on the way to vo
on the go into the voice because i was
looking outside the window in the car
thinking like
all of it's true like i had never really
gone to the beach the closest i've ever
really gotten was my parents taking me
to florida
like one time and my sister got my toe
caught in the
uh revolving door and like i had to go
to the hospital as a nightmare and my
parents swore would never go on vacation
again but most parents say
don't mean it my parents [ __ ] met it
meant it we never went on vacation again
that's crazy that you did all that work
and you never went on vacation
well i went on my own vacations we
didn't go on a family vacation that song
is so
obviously written by you yeah and that
was one of the things that i think i
liked about it
that it was uh when you listen to
someone sing a song like a really good
song
it's an expression of who they are at
that point in time in their life and you
can get wrapped up in their mind
you know and i felt like that's why i
like listening to other people i like
listening to songs before i go on stage
because it gets me out of my own head
and it gets me into someone else's head
and then when it's time to go you know
and they're like you're on in three like
okay and then i'll take the headphones
off i'll do a shot
i'll stretch out a little and then here
we go that's me oh hell yeah
that is that's me listening to your
[ __ ] song crazy
yeah legit i'm not lying that's nuts
well that's an honor i play that when
anthony was listening to he's like you
[ __ ] idiot what are you listening to
that's [ __ ] wild i never ever ever
would have thought that never would have
thought that
i like it thank you i like your music
thank you and i like you you're a good
person
thank you so much youtube i enjoyed
talking to you i did too i'm glad we did
this i agreed
so um you got something that's out right
now yeah
what is it how do people get it well
uh it's called midnight sky and
even just the title is kind of inspired
by debbie harry's heart of glass but i
pulled inspiration from edges 17 two of
my favorite songs heart of glass the
reason i love it so much is
that the title isn't the repetition in
the chorus
it's just a cool thing to say it's not
the chorus at all
um and so i thought you know what my
favorite part about it is is i love the
the kind of visual painting of midnight
sky and what that means
um and the midnight sky to me is like if
you're really [ __ ] partying
the moon is a disco ball and the stars
are all the reflection of light on the
ceiling
and what i really like about the disco
ball is that it's a bunch of broken
pieces put back together again that when
you're finally enlightened
it makes this mesmerizing totally
attractive like
people it's like you know it's like the
bugs to the light like people love disco
balls but it's really just a bunch of
broken
pieces put together and so i felt like
that was reflective of me
wow pretty deep to think about it that's
heavy yeah that's heavy but when i saw
it i thought like i recognized this
this is what i feel like all right so
that's it what sends it on there and
it's everywhere it's on youtube
streaming and yeah it's everywhere and
i'm making it so hopefully people will
watch it
all right you're a bad [ __ ]
thank you thank you thanks bye everybody
cool
i like being in here this is
you